what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to
the pregame
before I start do not forget to
subscribe to the channel and ring that
notification Bell that way you're going
to be notified of my daily videos
um a couple announcements before I start
the show the first is that we have two
clips channels the first is just Pearl
eclipse and pearl daily make sure you go
subscribe to both
um also guys we have four membership
tiers the first tier lets you be a part
of our live chat tonight the second tier
you get to be you get to see our Discord
and our behind the scenes Vlogs third
tier you get to connect with me on
social media and fourth tier you get a
one-on-one call with me once a month do
you want to know how to get a million
subscribers in a year sign up for that
call and I will tell you I go over
things like YouTube tag YouTube titles
and even how to recruit for a live show
I'll tell you the whole system also guys
um they took away my first Instagram so
go follow my second just pearly things
one um we're on Rumble you know just in
case we ever get kicked off of YouTube
one day you never know
um wife school go subscribe to that um
that's our other channel I'm learning
how to need I learned how to knead bread
the other day so subscribe we drop that
video
um also guys we have two talents at the
network Auntie Jenny and King Richie's
make sure you go subscribe to both we
also have a jpt network uh Clips channel
so make sure you go subscribe to that as
well
um we only have one official pregame
page on Instagram so make sure you go
follow that and
um King what did we say a thousand two
hundred to open up the chat so a
thousand two hundred likes to open up
the chat today
okay that is all my announcements for
now I think unless I forgot one but for
now okay
um today we have a lovely panel welcome
to the show everybody
um we are gonna go around and everyone
say your name your age your relationship
status and a fun fact um also shout out
John Anthony lifestyle um he's our
special guest today
um a dating coach and I actually went to
one of his boot camps like what two
years ago now yeah that was pretty crazy
I think I think just a quick shout out
there I think there was eight students
right three coaches and you saw one of
the nights seven of the guys took yeah
yeah so yeah that was that was crazy
actually real game yeah
um so starting here and then go around
and then go second row go ahead awesome
I'm Lexi I'm 23. relationship status
debating questionable open fun fact
can I I like to be in the nose
are you in like a talking phase or is it
talking yeah okay but you're still open
in case that doesn't work out exactly
okay okay uh fun fact I started radio
station just for the fun so oh that is
so fun thanks okay go ahead
hi guys I am Tia Marie I am 21.
um and
um yeah so I am single and healing
period um period
um
literally I'm sorry don't come for me
guys
um and fun fact about me
well fun fact about me I don't know oh
okay I'm into cars I'm going to cause
and um like that kind of lifestyle and
stuff like that what's your favorite car
my favorite car is a Golf GTI
um remapped free stage free if you know
about that yeah you must be yeah because
I don't know
all right go ahead
hi everyone my name is inasiaki and I am
32. I think I'm the oldest girl here I'm
not sure yet well let's see fun fact
about me I can't think of one right now
but I I'm very funny I can be very funny
but I can be the meanest girl I ever
know so it depends I think that's that's
fun enough okay so yeah that's a bit
about me okay go ahead hey guys Trey
hello here 48. fun fact to be well it's
not really a fun fact it's more passion
of mine is actually men ran a room on
clubhouse with my lovely fiancee over
here really empowering men and we had
about 10 000 men over the space of year
and I guess the fun fact really is that
men are really dealing with stuff in
life today so I'm really looking forward
to it I have to say one thing more fun
fact about him he is the body Groove guy
he doesn't share about that song yeah as
an ever never life I'm also a musician
probably most known by a lot of people
in there oh wow UK as well but let me
talk about men
hi my name is Liz I'm 30 years old I am
married to John and a fun fact about me
I would say because yesterday I said one
today I'm gonna say it's like I have
three beautiful French bulldogs and it's
like there's a lot of trouble so that's
really cool
uh John uh run the channel John Anthony
lifestyle I'm gonna turn 40 in October
fun fact uh slept at 1 600 girls and
tattooed the significance on my fingers
wow um but also what was really cool
last night I took her out for the first
time in London and we met a girl and
brought her back home and then she we
totally were going on just probably
things and she actually subscribes to
your channel oh wow so that was cool
women don't usually so I'm a little
surprised
um go ahead hi everyone I'm Stephanie
and I'm also 32.
um I am single at the moment and fun
fact about me is that I absolutely love
dancing especially salsa and it's got to
the point where it's something that I
will not sacrifice when dating if you
can't dance if you have no rhythm I'm
not interested
uh hi my name's Alicia I'm 21.
birthday is next month uh 22 next month
that's my fun fact and I'm in a
relationship
okay so today's topic we're talking
about sexless men so
a study published in the art Archives of
sexual behavior found that the number of
sexually inactive young adults has
increased in recent years a survey
conducted by the General Social Survey
which found that the percentage of men
under 30 who have not had had sex in the
past year has tripled since 2008. a
study published in Jama Pediatrics which
found that fewer teens are having sex
than in previous generations a study
found in the Journal of adolescent
health health which which found that
social media use is associated with a
decrease in sexual activity among
adolescents according to a 2017 study
the number of sexually inactive men in
the U.S has tripled in the past decade
the percentage of men aged 18 to 29 who
have not had had sex in the past year
increased from 9.5 percent in 2008 to 28
in 2018. there are a number of potential
reasons for this trend including the
rise of Technology social media and
video games which can be addictive and
time consuming economic factors such as
lack of job opportunities and financial
insecurity may also Inc may also
contribute to men delaying marriage and
sexual activity changes in gender norms
and expectations as well as a shift
towards more casual dating and hookup
culture may also be factors this trend
is not not unique to the U.S where there
are similar patterns in other countries
including the UK and Japan some experts
argue that the trends towards sexual
inactivity is not necessarily a negative
and may reflect a broader shift towards
a greater emphasis on personal
fulfillment and self-care
so according to the article the number
of sexless men under 30 has tripled in
the last decade why do you guys think
that's happening
so
I don't know about the US yeah
I think in the UK young people are
having sex more I just think
we're not having as much kids like as
the previous generation I feel like
people were having kids younger or
having a lot of children I feel like
we're just not having kids we're having
sex
I want to have kids so you think they're
like lying when they're surveyed about
it I don't know about them about the
lion yeah but
from being in the UK and how I know guys
that you know are out here I don't think
men have become like sexist at all
I think sorry tried to call you but you
can speak after me I think also there is
a massive change in confidence
in men I don't know what happened with
this gender thing but also it's there's
a massive impact when man is confused
and it's playing in their confident like
I think the generation right now the
kids that I'm seeing right now there's a
massive difference between them and the
generation that I know so boys what do
you think caused that
um there's a lot of culture you know
even the songs that you hear like six
figure blah blah blah I think mine are
questioning if they're good enough to
actually go out on dates and take girls
out and you know be with these type of
girls that they fancy or they have to
settle for something that they're not
which most of men do but I think there's
a massive crisis I would say that's
happening to the Young Generation and
it's the whole songs the culture
everything that's happening contributing
to The Confident of the young boys right
now comparing to the generation before
and it's a bit shocking yeah so you
think that masculinity was celebrated
before and it's not now
I definitely think so
um yes and it's funny enough even I
think also a lot of men are put in a lid
to who they are and what they need and
what they want and their identities been
really like there's a crisis of their
identity because of what like the
conversation that we're having and the
songs of everything the whole culture is
definitely suppressing that a hundred
percent I definitely think there is a
bit of a crisis of masculinity going on
with a lot of young men where I mean if
I think of someone my age we have so
many
strong male role models
and we didn't have the distraction of
this little device in our hands that
just sucked in all of our
potential almost as men and the humans
being as human beings and now men don't
have their role models so they almost
don't know how to be there's a backdrop
I guess of the metoo movement a lot of
genuine movements that needed to happen
and I think it's left a lot of men
discombobulated how they approach women
should they approach women what's
appropriate you know if you think a lot
of our parents probably met in Social
settings or you know through families
Etc but certainly the social aspect of
meeting people at the gym at the pub at
the bar I think a lot of men are
frightened to do that some of it is
societal like this I guess some people
see it as an attack on masculinity and
some of it is the men themselves failure
to almost move with the modern times so
we've drawn into their computer games
they've withdrawn into this world where
they're almost just with themselves or
with their peers they've forgot the art
of actually engaging in conversations
chatting people up and doing stuff and I
think also another aspect is I think
we're a bit in the victim culture a
little bit in life as well where people
see himself as victims and Paul me and I
miss the world owes them something I'm
sure there are a lot of and I don't mean
to be bad when I say but a lot of angry
men who seem that they by default should
just have stuff without having to put
the work in so it's almost like an
entitlement with guys because they're
not putting the work in they don't know
how to or they're scared to do it as a
result a lot of them are unintentionally
sexist I don't think they want to be but
I think it's unintentionally so there's
so many different factors that are
contributing to it especially more so
with men and then I guess there's also
the factor of women going for that top
20 or the top 30 of men as we see of
these Tinder studies so most men are not
going to pass that standard anymore so
they're going to be left their sort of
sort of scratching ass thinking what can
I do and a lot of them are choosing to
withdrawn I think it's quite dangerous
as well you've seen it with a lot of the
shooting and stuff that's happened in
America they can become quite angry and
quite disaffected and it can become
quite dangerous for society can you
expound a little bit more what you said
that you said phones are ruining men's
potential yeah because phones are this
illusion of life but it's not real so if
you're always got your head in your
phone or you've got your head in video
games how the hell do you how the hell
do you become who you're born to be how
the hell do you you know get the level
of Charisma the level of confidence she
needs if you're always in the phone it's
not a real world you know go and talk to
that woman at a bar go and talk to that
woman on the street go and engage with
an actual human being rather than your
phone it's very easy I think to be
buried in your phone and the more you do
it the more disengaged you are from
actual real world where you need to
speak to people well you can't blame
them it's actually there's so many
there's so many different factors that
are contributing to them needing almost
I guess they feel they need to disengage
from society safer to be porn as well do
what access to Corn how easy it is
yeah I think that exactly yeah and again
that's another aspects of your phone and
Technology it's much easier for guys to
get online and engage in corn and again
not be engaged in the real world and
then get into this unrealistic World of
War
you know intimacy is for them intimacy
if it's just born that's not intimacy
that's just one side of it but rural
intimacies engage in its share and it's
been vulnerable it's allowing yourself
to be seen and to see others and they're
not engaging in that anymore in that
same way do you think that's true for a
man and for women I think more so for me
we're just speaking about this before
everyone came in I think it's generally
harder for men because men have to graft
no one's coming to save a man I think
society would happily step over a man's
corpse you say what 75 of homelessness
is men something like again similar stat
when it comes to Suicide I don't think
Society cares about men in fact people
probably laugh oh men they're not having
sex oh it's just funny you know so
there's all these these different things
you know and I think and because I do a
lot of advocacy for men I think for my
my stance is men need to be responsible
for the state of their lives I don't
necessarily think Society owes them
anything I'd love Society to care about
men to care about masculinity to see the
value that men bring to the world God
but Society may not in fact the trend
seems to be going the other way I want
men to start actually looking what can I
be responsible for let me put my phone
away let me put down Call of Duty let me
actually start to engage I know that
especially for younger people it's a bit
of a mindful because what was normal for
my generation chatting up a girl on the
street or wherever it might be for some
people might be seen as some sort of
attack almost that's what Society said
but I think men need to almost stand in
their courage and just go for it and if
things they can do it with Charisma with
respect they can start to engage but men
are checking out and I think the the
ramifications of that disaster is not to
mention the fact that relationships
break down there are a lot of men from
single parent families a lot of these
things you know that also the absence of
a father okay because it's really
serious yeah it plays a massive part
yeah and then these men are raised by
women and they're the women are a bit
angry you know and they're just like
raising them to be scared you know
they're not raising them to be
you know men you know they raise them
from a woman point of view that she's
been used and abused by men so he's kind
of lost his identity
that that's playing in my support
sorry that the survey is it speaking
about a specific age group
um young men mostly like between up to
29 okay because I totally agree with
what you guys are saying when with the
younger guys but something that I've
personally noticed out on the street is
that the older guys that now have
families and have children they're the
ones you see during the day pushing the
buggies and we've two free kids on the
street so where roles are reversed maybe
now the men are tired spending all day
with the kids and then during the night
when the wife comes home or they're both
both of them are at home they're like
you know what I'm really tired I just
don't want to have anything for men
that's what I that's what I'm seeing on
the streets maybe the roles have been
reversed where usually would be the
woman I gotta I gotta be a bitly
disagree
to have sex just after even speaking to
like divorce attorneys um like the a
common complaint is that men um they
have two kids and then the wife stops
sleeping with them and I've talked to
like different attorneys in the uh
because I'm doing a documentary in the
court system here and I've talked to
different
um divorce attorneys in the US and the
UK and it's the same problem that sounds
more realistic because like the women
are like my body's not the same he
probably doesn't see me the same and
they just let go but guys know they
actually they want that they want to
sleep with you after you've had kids
because you're the person that they
married and all those things but I think
women just think because I've given him
kids he's not gonna want anything else
do you think that's unfair to man 100
yeah 100 because at the end of the day
men needed more
you know yeah yeah yeah what do you guys
think why um are so many more men
sexless so like I've been coaching this
stuff now for 10 years and I see a lot
of guys they go and try to get better
with this stuff a lot of the pickup
artist teachings are misleading and they
don't work and then they just fall into
some kind of victim ideology right so
they think okay I'm gonna just fall into
red pill and resent women and hate women
and women are the enemy or they think
well I don't look like a model so that's
why I can't get girls like the whole
black pill stuff or they go to mgtow and
they say I'm not gonna even bother
dating and a lot of guys are already
self-conscious about their height or
about how old they are about how much
money they have and we were talking
before the show like we both coached a
lot of guys guys come in to interactions
just assuming like they're not good
enough for for whatever reasons and then
it becomes a self-fulfilling prophecy
because they have a negative mindset and
they go down this kind of negative
spiral and then they give up because
they don't have any other options
there's no like light at the end of the
tunnel and they try to do these things
and there's also this unrealistic
standard like on Instagram and stuff
like that where you just see people like
this is all perfect and this and that
and so guys are trying to compare
themselves to that and they're like well
this isn't for me so a lot of guys are
just be become more and more on the
sidelines just spectating other guys
right and so it's kind of like feast or
famine like once I teach you how to how
to get a proper mindset and do all the
system properly what changes do you
teach them I tell them to think that
they're at 100 out of 100 at all times
and there's a brick wall between them
and the external things that happen so
if they get rejected or they get
insulted or anything like that their
value stays at 100 out of 100 because
they're driving it from internally
they're not letting people's reactions
and people's responses Define their
worth and then also I tell them to
assume they got the girl before they go
approach like in public and that makes a
huge huge difference like he was saying
he focuses really heavily on the mindset
that's like most of the battle right
there's still tons of strategic elements
but if the guy is thinking that he's not
good enough and he's trying to win the
girl over he's already coming at it from
the wrong angle and girls pick up on
that right away and they think okay this
guy is low value because he thinks I'm
way above him so I'm not I don't teach
guys to think they're better than the
girls just think they're good enough for
any girl and still keep working on
themselves and better themselves as much
as possible but that's an empowering
message and we usually get clients that
are that are virgins or divorcees or
anything like that we get them late like
in the first week and you saw on the on
the boot camp like a lot of those guys
had never taken girls home before and
part of it is getting them to believe in
themselves but the other part of it is
giving them the proper strategy to know
how to navigate through the whole system
because there can be bottlenecks any
step of the way like guys are using
random Tinder pictures they're not going
to get many matches if they get a match
they're going to send wrong messages if
they get a phone number they're going to
send their own texts and so it's very
hard for them to make it through the
whole process and they get deflated and
then they just give up and then they
just go to these other side movements
and they just all like sit on these
forums and watch these creators that
just victimize everyone I think that's
very sad because a lot of these guys
just need proper coaching like you saw
like a lot of a lot of clients that I
get Bounce from coach to coach and they
didn't get anywhere but they weren't
being given the proper mindset the
proper system and then when you give
them that the results are just almost
instant what do you think starts the
problem though so it's like if they
if they've worms or to these YouTube
channels or whatever like something had
to start it where it's different today
than it was 50 years ago what do you
think that is I think you know just with
with the Advent of of social media and
stuff like that and there's there's just
so much like like this Tinder statistics
right it's like if guys aren't using
professional pictures the first thing we
do when a guy signs up for my my week
programs we get in professional pictures
and then Liz and some other girls on the
team pick the top five and then we apply
face app so they're going from like
average photos to Pro photos to the best
five Pro photos to the faceapped
versions and now they're getting like a
night and day difference in the quantity
and quality of matches whereas you know
before they might have just put up
whatever pictures didn't get the result
and then they see their friend maybe
like one of their cool guy friends he's
getting a lot of girls but they don't
know how to navigate that properly but
then when they look on social media they
see you know these perfect looking
people and they say well I'm not perfect
looking right now I have these flaws and
people have these different handicaps
they place in themselves where they are
cognizant of all these different flaws
they have of and then they think that
that makes them not good enough for the
girls and then that causes the rejection
and then that like reinforces the belief
and then it just continues in a cycle
right and people are you know not many
people are called approaching anyways
like even even in your Generation stuff
like that no but it's gotten even less
calmly yeah much less and with covid and
stuff like this you know not many people
were going out and I I think that even
once like night venues and stuff
reopened not as many people go out
anymore and a lot of clients I work with
their ego is like very tied to
approaching a female in public so if
that girl rejects them they feel
horrible about themselves and it's it's
tough for them to go back in and try
again and then if that rejection happens
again and it keeps it's like it's like a
negative momentum and then they they
just usually give up so my job is to to
show them like look you you can totally
do this and show them real tangible
results and that starts a positive
momentum and then they end up with a
place of options and they can pick the
best one for the girlfriend or something
like this what do you what what do you
think about the men that say they're
afraid to approach because of the metoo
movement
I mean that's a very real thing like I
live in Brazil that stuff's not really
going on over there yet but in the
western Nations it's it's a really bad
thing I just did a video on my Channel
about like in Scotland if you're talking
about like a sexual conquest and a woman
over here is you can be sent to jail you
can be sent to jail yeah it's like a new
thing why yeah and in England too like I
I correct me if I'm wrong but like if
you like cat call go on the street you
can get in trouble now right you can
Google it I don't know I'm pretty sure
that like yeah but it depends like I
have to be something like
I don't know it depends they won't
arrest you they won't respectable
offense it says this legislation well
this legis wait this leg this
legislation will criminal criminalize
Acts including cat calling and making
offensive gestures and walking too
closely behind something at night yes
like the Scotland thing it's if you
brush up against someone and I've been
in tons of nightclubs right so I spent a
lot of my time in my life for better or
worse but you know inadvertently you're
going to be brushing up against people
when you're packed in into a club and
that's that can put you in jail now in
Scotland if you brush up against someone
so what do you say to guys that are in
countries with laws like that do you
tell them not to approach or what's your
what's your solution as a dating coach I
mean if they I tell them to move if they
can I mean that's pretty extreme but
like in Australia for instance like they
have a new thing where women can change
their mind about consent during sex
and that's you know I have Australian
clients and and they're just terrified
they don't even want to get in a sexual
situation because there's no one there
to witness that so it's just he said she
said right and they're going to take the
side of the girl in a lot of the cases
I'm not saying that like bad stuff
doesn't happen but it makes guys very
apprehensive same with the Scotland
stuff guys were already afraid to go and
approaching now they don't want to have
legal trouble right so as these
countries and what they're trying to do
is combat harassment of women these are
real problems but when they impose these
very strict kind of lockdown measures
then it turns men away from speaking and
leads to the statistics
I'm curious um because you've lived like
everywhere yeah what what is your
experience dating in different countries
so I lived in Poland and Ukraine and I
often talk on my channel that the the
women are just much more family oriented
it's almost almost like the US like 50
years ago so it's like they're more like
feminine elegant
um kind of stronger moral system looking
for kind of family stuff like that
on on the flip side of the coin they
take longer to hook up with which was
annoying right like in Ukraine it would
take like two to five dates to to
actually hook up with a girl added
situations where I'd be in a fourth date
in public and they weren't ready to kiss
yet which I've never encountered
anywhere else but there's not a lot of
this you know
um kind of me too stuff that's happening
in the US and happening in in the UK and
stuff like that but again these are very
real problems that need to be addressed
but when they say that you can't speak
about
you know hooking up with a girl with an
earshot of another woman or you can't
brush up against someone even if it was
an accident or stuff like this it starts
to blur the line between you know guys
just living their life versus
potentially encountering trouble and
guys want to err on the side of caution
a lot of cases and the things we've
already discussed about how guys are
already apprehensive that adds to it and
they just figure you know I'm not gonna
even bother with that I'm just gonna
watch corn I guess or stuff like this
that's interesting so you really think
that the metoo movement has contributed
to male sexless sexlessness yes they
don't want the rest yeah because I
because I have access to like thousands
of clients and I hear these things all
the time and you know the guys in
Australia
a lot of them couldn't even leave
because of the you know during the
pandemic but they're really terrified
about getting in a situation where a
girl later says hey I changed my mind
about consent and then what happens from
there right or or a guy you know
approaching a girl and she doesn't like
it maybe in the UK is he now going to
get in trouble right so
as we said not many people are called
approaching to begin with but when you
put these kind of restrictions on guys
are even more intimidated right because
now there's not just rejection there's
also legal consequences has that ever
happened to any of your clients or
someone you know
um getting in trouble for for no I can't
think of any any instances but I think
it's more of uh it just makes people gun
shy yeah it's more that it could happen
yeah yeah they don't want to you know
just the fact that that exists and makes
them just not want to even be part of
that so like why you know they don't
want to put their freedom on the line or
something like that to get a hookup yeah
that's kind of because again I'm doing
the documentary on the court system here
and I'm starting to like learn
um you don't even have to be married
it's a crazy thing it's just with a kid
um just the that guys go through
um especially with getting access to
their kids and they can get a lot of
false accusations because here
um they're literally paid they're given
free counsel if you accuse a guy of
assault and a lot of the centers here
know that so they incur urge the woman
to do it
um yeah and even though it doesn't
happen to every guy I'm like listening
to these stories I'm like if I was like
I would be so I've heard a lot of
stories like that from clients where
like basically like like women that
cheat for instance if the the husband
finds out like I've heard of a lot of
situations where the guy
um gets screwed because the woman just
says you know the guy that hooked up the
woman just says like it was
non-consensual just so she can save the
marriage and there's no consequence on
the woman again I'm not saying like
sexual assault doesn't happen it's not a
real problem but it's like a nice little
like roll of the dice in in a bunch of
cases where I know people specifically
where you know it's like a real danger
even even in the U.S like a guy I had a
client where he he basically like
um had sexually grow in Las Vegas in a
hotel room and she said oh I paid for
the room like stay the night and he said
I'm gonna leave and she ran down and
said oh you know he he graped me
basically and you know situations like
that or if they cheat and then the
partner finds out it's just very easy to
say it wasn't consensual so they can
save the marriage and they don't care
what happens to the guy's life right and
then it just becomes a hit she said yes
curious for their girls if you were in
the position of guys where the laws were
against you I didn't just say something
about it it's interesting right
and so a lot of people do mention toxic
masculinity but I definitely think the
the crisis that's happening and I can
see it it's a Phi label it is from toxic
feminist feministy I can't really say
the word problem because how do you how
do you expect people to express
themselves when they're scared men boys
are so scared to express themselves to
approach you but the main complaint from
all of my girlfriends or the people that
I know is the man or not being men
enough yeah they're not like literally
approaching exactly but look they're
created there but then when we have laws
like that how can because I'm just
thinking if I was in their point of view
and you guys can tell me if you agree or
disagree but I would be really hesitant
and then also We complain about men that
wanting to get married but if you look
at the lows in here in the west I won't
get married why would I get married and
like Risk 50 of my income mainly I make
the most out of that income and I don't
think that's fair as well there is there
is a privilege for women and there is a
man privilege as well and I think it's
not even marriage it's um it's just
having a kid exactly that's the crazy
thing I just talked to this guy um the
other day and he wasn't legally married
he just had a kid here
um and what she did was she um went to
like a woman's shelter and basically at
the women's shelter they tell the girls
like what to say about the guy based on
his background I know he's some of these
people yeah and so um for him he was
Muslim and she basically said that
everything she did the last 10 years she
didn't actually consent to doing because
it was under his control like control
allegedly even though she was fine with
it while they were married yes and then
they don't really get a fair shot in
court yeah and and it took him over a
year to actually get to go to court so
he didn't see his kid for a year with no
evidence yeah yeah and that's normal
yeah it's normal and you know what's
funny I think things are changing now
after Amber yeah you know I think the
court and people and judges are kind of
like looking for more evidence and then
thinking okay maybe Are there women are
using this listen I stand up for women I
love women but I think also abusing men
I don't stand for it I think there's
have to be a balance between men
femininity and masculinity and you have
to honor each other you know what you
say is that balance isn't it because I
think there was a movement at one point
where it was believe all women which
goes completely against our tenants of
actual you know innocent unto proven
guilty it was just if a woman says it
then it's and I get it where it's come
from like you said earlier I mean you
know there's been a lot of historical
wrongs against women so there was a real
natural need to you know redress that
but I think the pendulum is just swung
so full of to the other way where it's
like everyone's suffering men are
suffering but now women actually
suffering because there are like you say
a lot of your friends are single because
men are terrified and I I I I get the
cries from some quarters in society
where people say it's a deliberate thing
to actually completely dismantle
relationships because that almost seems
the only logical explanation is like
there's almost like this real concerned
effort to completely dismantle marriage
because there's any way you can explain
it to a certain extent isn't it because
some of the laws are so crazy so stupid
I'm so Sinister there is like that is
not fostering proper relationships
proper marriage and we can see the stats
of you know especially boys from single
parent families I mean my God from crime
to health to life chances to every stat
goes against them so why are we a
society pushing this real almost like an
agenda to split people up have you ever
thought about it how it changes the
Dynamics of relationships because when
you think about it if you're okay if
you're in a deal right with someone yeah
and one party gains everything by
leaving and one party loses everything
by Leading leaving the person that loses
everything is always going to be trying
to appease the one that gains everything
and so and so I feel like that's why we
get we get
um phrase is like she wears the pants in
the relationship yeah because her wife
happy life yeah yeah yeah because 80 of
relationships are in this oh sorry 80 of
divorces are initiated by women right
women I mean it's no surprise guys would
be terrified isn't it yeah Paul just
going back to what you said about
um you know like women that flee from
men and will make up this story and
stuff like that in the UK it is so easy
to do that it's so easy to say you know
um I'm in this situation like for
example that person that you know they
said I was with a Muslim guy he done
this this and this it's so easy for
women to do that for women to go to
shelters and for men it's like it's
they're not even heard like at all well
it's cousin Family Court I'm learning
about this now so I might butcher it but
it's up to the discretion of a judge
um so normally like if you go to
Criminal Court you you have to convince
a jury and that's a little and it's
based on evidence we're in family court
it's based on a balance of problem
abilities so they're not even a hundred
percent sure he's guilty in the UK this
is even before the court like yeah yeah
like if you could I don't really know
like the lines and stuff but if you for
example said to your doctor I mean this
even though you might not be you could
say I'm in this relationship this person
is like you know domestic violence I
have a child you can leave that night
and then they'll take you to like a
refuge or something like it's so easy
for women I'm not saying that there's
not women out there that actually do
need that because they do but there's
also women that are taking advantage of
that and once you get to that point you
can get benefits you can get housing
like there's so much more but before the
court I'm saying like before the course
well and they kick him out of the house
because that's what he was telling me he
was saying you first go to either a
teacher or a doctor and then they take
you to the women's shelter and they tell
you what to say and then one call um to
the police they have the women's shelter
instructs you and what to say to the
police so he's gone basically yeah the
police can take them the next day yeah
yeah and so um one like there's one guy
who got one call and it was I forgot
what exactly the words he said but it
was basically like get out of the house
and he still has to pay for the mortgage
on the house because it's in his name
and then he slapped with 1500 in child
support a month easily and then he lost
his job because he was so yeah you know
I mean he just lost his kids and
everything he owned I have one client
that basically
um he built the whole you know financial
situation the wife was staying home with
the kids and he came home one day early
from work and his wife was with another
guy and you know the guy was like
running out the back door whatever but
what's interesting is that she ended up
getting the whole house like almost full
custody of the kids and like totally
ruined his life but he didn't do
anything wrong right just the way the
system is set up and that doesn't mean
like oh everyone needs to go mgtow now
and don't ever get married but that
really like calls into question here
that was not even something he did you
know he didn't do anything wrong but the
courts are going to side with the woman
in most cases and Western World yeah and
that's it's hard because
there's not really a way to avoid it out
here because even the guy that I talked
to the other day he wasn't legally
married it was just okay you don't even
need to be married like it's just it's
so easy like as soon as you go through
the doctor that that day they will send
you to like
the
do you know someone that's happened to
yeah that's right tell me what happened
um so I know somebody that was in just
in a normal relationship no problem
whatever but they needed housing no yeah
like there's nothing to do with a
partner so they just created their own
partner in the head got into a refuge no
way waited a year was in temporary
housing
and then got into a flat so do you need
like any type of evidence you don't need
evidence like well no nowadays they're
cracking onto it more but I know back
then it was easy if you if I said I'm
gonna they don't even need to know the
guy if I just and I just literally they
don't even listen to me a fake person
and I'm not saying that I haven't done
dust or live at home I'm just saying
example right people but that's how easy
it is in the UK like people take
advantage of the system
so yeah the number of abuse allegations
increased uh 200 percent when they
implemented that law I think it was
2013. um so yeah it's like you're
getting hit you okay yeah I'm not saying
that that doesn't happen though I'm not
being insensitive but I'm just being
real do you guys think okay if the roles
were reversed and we had those
repercussions for being with men yeah
would you change your behavior I I want
to talk to anyone you want to talk to
anyone you know what's funny I think I'm
I'm curious I haven't heard from you yet
so I want to hear eggshells I would be
walking on eggshells I would be so
paranoid it'd be paranoid to the point
where it's like it's not even a point in
talking to anyone I'll just do me focus
on me someone comes my way they come my
way I wouldn't even go out looking for
people because I would be so scared of
what could come from it legally some
guys
um put ring all over their apartment so
they can't say that anything that was
consensual like wasn't consensual yeah
but then wouldn't that be um
like they're recording it without your
content I have no idea if that's legal
yeah you can't Record sex acts yeah
that's where they draw the line right so
like I I advise clients to have like you
know at least they come outside your
house or in situations where it is legal
so you can show I actually spoke to a
lawyer about this because because I've
been sleeping a lot of girls I said how
do I protect myself and he said I'll
just send a text did you have a good
time I said that's not guaranteed
they're going to respond even if they
did right so an objective empirical
account that shows like this person's
living on good terms and this and that
I've never had any accusation luckily
with all these girls but I have plenty
of clients that have and a lot of times
like I mentioned before it's because the
person cheated and then they just want
to save the marriage and it's like you
know there's no consequence for doing
that really if the girl is lying which
is unfortunate but I think just proceed
with caution is I would say and you know
just yeah just like I don't know like in
some countries it's a bit more strict I
feel like even though you the UK might
say some of these things I haven't
actually heard them until today can I
just say something also
I think also in the west and it's
naturally right a lot of a lot of men go
after
these type of women and they they like
them it's attractive these type of women
that will
how would I say the word
crazy no no they will F them up okay
yeah yeah because they're attractive
they're sexy they're whatever it is but
you don't understand you turned around
like you created that monster woman have
to be looking that certain way wait that
certain way blah blah blah she needs to
and then this woman become your worst
enemy because this woman is a gold
digger you have to keep maintaining her
looks her you know going out every night
in these type of restaurants and she
will use you and abuse you but we a man
most of the time aren't attracted to
this type of woman and they complain
about what these women do for them but
they don't honor a lot of nice girls
that they don't look like 10 out of 10.
it's the same reverse too right like
women that women don't want a nice guy
100 it's it's natural people are just
for women and men exactly it is
attractive I also we do I also think
that man you really don't know what
someone's gonna do when they're when
they're scorned when they're pissed off
and I think you can see see a different
side of people when there's a breakup
but that's what I'm saying and that's
the thing it's not that like women are
worse than men or men are worse than
women wait but it's that women are given
the tools to destroy men if they so want
to yeah I am interesting to see what
type of world would be living in when
that's been reversed yeah well I mean
you could go back a hundred years ago it
wasn't the no-fault divorce started in
90s 70s I don't remember but 100 years
ago it wasn't like that oh look at the
east east let's see that was one of the
problems because when men did have that
power Society saw some men is abusing it
so you know there was a natural sense
you know to kind of balance it but like
I said it's just the pendulum has gone
too far and I think what's happened is
people have just lost their balls people
are not courageous enough to say enough
you know men and women come together and
say it's enough it's gone too far
everybody is suffering how can we do it
together and we've created this
polarized world where everyone's on each
other's backs you know men against women
black against white rich against Paul
and no one's come together and say what
kind of society do we want to live in
and how courageous do we need to be to
create it it's not going to be perfect
and there's always going to be losers
but we need to create this because
everyone's suffering but no one's doing
that and it feels like society and the
powers that a b have created this like
what you just said pal I mean the fact
that you've got rumble on standby just
shows there's a lot of I know you have a
lot of your detractors a lot of your
hates I get it but there is something
really important about what you're
trying to say same way Kevin Samuels God
Rest his soul there's a lot of stuff
that people are trying to say but the
minute they say they're shut down but we
need to hear his point of view how can
we say it when there's so much things
coming out like it's like now you have
to think of it well not in my world but
now it's not just male and female
there's like all the in between
intersectionality exactly so how can we
even but no one's waiting everybody stop
and let's do it this way or let's try
today we can't because we've got to
think of this one this one and this one
is it's almost like the majority of
people are sensible thinking but people
are scared and I think we're letting the
agenda be run by the
fringersexual people like how what
percent of people are even or even trans
or he she whatever the hell it is it's
like it's like what one two percent of
the population and we all have to cater
to them yeah yeah the kids in the
schools yeah that's how it's well not in
the real world but I feel like on social
media that's what they're catering to
it's like in the schools I'm I'm scared
to you know have my kids go to to actual
school I'll home school my kids if by
the time I have children there's certain
because I don't want them to think
that's okay I don't want them to think
yeah I don't want them to like for
example like Peppa Pig right this is
gonna sound so random but about two
months ago I saw on Peppa Pig they
changed it it was like same-sex sort of
thing and I don't have
a problem or whatever with same-sex or
lesbian or whatever but my child's
seeing that and said like a mummy and a
mummy can't have a baby like that's the
really well it's like why do they need
to know why do they need to know that
they're so innocent like they're just if
they if they want it's exactly like now
it's more like fours fours not saying
that I'm against anything no I'm just
saying now it's more pressure and it's
popular yeah yeah it's a trend it's a
trend to be bisexual there's so many
girls I know especially like our age
group like 21 is like yeah I'm bisexual
like it's a trend you know so
so um
guys what is more important to you when
looking at a guy
money or looks
I have a third one I'm not gonna lie
yeah
money money yeah no but if I say money
it's gonna sound like I'm a gold digger
don't worry about it
I'm gonna be real let me keep it real
baby
yeah same money yeah
money money actually I think I changed
my mind you know wait no but looks ain't
gonna pay the bills
after what I've been through money
definitely so if you were advising guys
would you tell them to get their money
up first or their Fitness if they only
had time for one oh Fitness oh sorry no
money but I'm just I'm just curious if
the results you guys have seen are the
same what's interesting for me like I
was bringing this up on the King
Richard's podcast yesterday is that I've
had tons of broke clients that spent the
last of their money on my training and
got rock star level results like just
getting tons of girls living at home
like doesn't matter like I've found that
money is very very like almost
irrelevant really as long as the guy's
not living in poverty I know online like
everyone thinks so true there's like so
many red pill creators that are like get
the bag and all this stuff but in
practice that's total BS but then you
think money makes a guy more confident
and more like I get worthy for I get the
other side of the coin though I get a
lot of like millionaire clients I
haven't had I was telling you before the
show a billionaire client and they're
just trying to lead with that right so
they're like I'm just gonna pick her up
in the Ferrari I think yeah yeah a guy
being in touch of his masculinity is
what makes him attractive and he doesn't
need money
yeah
money or looks yeah
exactly but one thing also when first of
all money can just tell you more about
his ambition yeah it's up to something
Fitness is more important than money for
sure because your body your health will
give you everything mental health you
can have your money today you lose it
tomorrow and you will be left alone with
the girl that you picked and you'll be
with the man that you picked and it's a
duty to work a life together that's a
commitment to relationship I should
agree that if your guy was unemployed he
only has so much time before you would
leave yes or no no depends on the
content so like like let's say five
years no job well that's a bit crazy
like no job at all
I need I I believe
that
the man is the lead like he is the one
that takes charge and if
he doesn't hold that up I just feel like
I couldn't stay with someone that should
there needs to be a drive when you're
working there's a drive there's a
motivation like you're working I'm
working like we're in this together like
I couldn't be with a man that's just
that's no motivation for me that's just
being lazy I think I'm being honest I
think it depends you know because it
depends if he's willing to work if he's
motivated to work whereas if he's not
motivated and he's fine he's just
chilling with no job no money for five
years and it's a bit of a problem but if
he's motivated he knows what he wants to
do he's just working towards his goals
or he's willing to work towards his
goals then I feel like that's okay like
we've all taken time out for ourselves
you don't know what he came up with to
be a doctor you don't know what he wants
to do baby you don't know what he wants
to do but like obviously everyone's
different and we're all quite young as
well like no no I don't believe that
everyone has their own opinion like a
side Hustle
a part-time job would you say would you
say a side hustle and Paul is um a job
would you class is the same thing aside
hustle on a job
uh so for example like only fans
I mean it's a jar it's still a job
um for a man not not for a guy
um
I think it's a job it's not a career
okay yeah it depends it depends on the
side hustle yeah it's a Broadhead yeah
it's a very broad yeah this is an
extreme example too right like there's
like gradients are you talking about
like does a guy need to be rich versus
like have just enough no you're talking
about like unemployed right my only
point was that at some point if he if
he's not making enough money we're gonna
leave that's at some
that's something yeah no I'm gonna agree
with that but I'm saying like the guy
has like his basic needs met yeah like I
found it doesn't really make much of a
difference if he has like a ton of money
except for certain girls
like jobless what's the difference okay
is it different in the Eastern European
countries versus the West yes I mean in
terms of money yeah I mean yeah because
most people are poor right like like in
in Ukraine and in Poland even in Brazil
like people are making
like a thousand dollars a month or less
so like you know it's like 10 grand a
year or less than 10 grand a year after
taxes so I mean you know it goes back to
those his basic needs met right that
basic needs are met I haven't found that
it makes much of a difference because
I've had so many rich clients that are
all clueless like they're all in their
their like millionaire circles and like
hey we thought this would get us the
girls and we got all the money and
there's no girls and then I have clients
that have hardly any money that just
Crush once they're doing things right
and the girl doesn't even know they
don't have money
but again like we're talking about like
unemployed like completely broke for
years versus at least having basic needs
met like a lot of guys like even if
they're not doing super well it wasn't
statistic it's like 80 of people are
living paycheck to paycheck in the US I
think is something like that so that
high wow I'm pretty sure yeah so it's
like if if they don't get paid one week
they can't pay the bills but that's like
almost all guys right so all this like
focus on oh you need to go make a lot of
money and there's a lot of creators that
say like forget dating just go focus on
making money when they arrive at the
money if they ever do most of them don't
even get the money but if they do it's
not like girls just start raining down
in their lap right do you guys think
that sex is a need that men can't live
without
sex is a need that men can't live
without it depends on what you mean
though like what's the time period I
mean without sex and they just living on
corn I think if you what do you think
would happen if there wasn't corn I
think I think society would be very
violent wouldn't it I think if you get a
lot of men are you see an animal kingdom
isn't it it's the same sort of thing
isn't it you get you know one alpha male
that's called the females and the others
are always fighting them for positions
yeah they're willing to fight to the
death I think you'd get quite a violent
society and that's one of the reasons
why monogamy came about was to stop that
because if you have men that are not
having sex and they're not getting that
frustration I guess out they're gonna
take it out on society I think if you
took away corn away from men I think
men's mental health would suffer
tremendously probably more so than women
is corn a net positive or negative it
depends on how you I think it can be a
negative because it creates it creates
lack of false like a fantasy and so when
you know you do go out with guys they
might be like they might be more forward
with sex or certain things because
they've seen certain things they might
have that expectation so I feel like
sometimes it can be quite pressuring and
it can I think sometimes as well that
corn is
sometimes that devaluing women I don't
know like it's kind of it doesn't it
doesn't make sex feel special yeah I
don't think it makes it more like you
were saying earlier like the intimacy it
just creates a fancy sometimes
I I could see where corn is a net
negative for guys in an individual level
but
I'm just gonna play devil's advocate
here I also think it's helped a lot of
guys stay faithful and sexless marriage
I was gonna say that I was gonna say
that yeah so it's so true I think
there's a place for it because if
imagine you're one of these guys and
your wife is that a kid or two kids
whatever she's just dealing with life
and I personally am a believer in
marriage I mean we're getting married
soon right I believe in marriage right I
believe if that can keep you going
through that period it's better to
engage in that than to actually cheat
cheat yeah and you're gonna risk a hell
of a lot and I think corn from that
point of view is good but I think too
much of it right like anything
where guys don't want to go out and do
anything because they're so yeah they're
addicted to it it stops them being about
their purpose they've got these
unrealistic views of women and for some
men especially men that are more prone
to that it might make them even more
violent because they got an demand it of
women and so I'm gonna do it by force I
mean most sexual assault is men are the
perpetrators of it and I think how much
is corn to blame for that you know on I
think it's typing something biological
person increases sexual assault I think
I I don't see why it would not because
if men are frustrated at home and all
they know is just being online at some
point you might want the real thing I
think I would think it would do I don't
know but I would think it would do the
opposite because like it gives them a
release instead of going but you've seen
some issues where men have actually
assaulted women where they've had this
addiction and they want to play out in
real life you see that often you know
there's a fantasy and they want to play
it in real life and they go by the point
I haven't seen one was there something
in the news or I've never seen that
wasn't that policeman actually got done
for that addicted to that the one that
um Sarah Edward I also had that I think
yeah yeah so what happened
actually drag the woman off the streets
and clap them I think he had an
addiction with porn if I'm not I mean
sorry I'm recording because um you know
and it's natural isn't it if that's all
you know is the virtual version of
something at some point it's quite easy
to spill
the same thing with video games like men
that play video games are going to be
more violent because I'm pretty sure the
evidence was the opposite with that I I
definitely don't believe I agree with I
I think that is true as well because for
example I don't know about not really in
the UK but I heard about a lot of school
shootings with like young people in
America like it's always to do with guns
and always to do with yeah like those
kind of like video games so I think that
definitely has an impact as well but
then that's like
everything has an impact with social
media and with technology because even
what we see online might change the way
that we move or we look so everything
does I think but I think it's only going
to amplify what's already there it's
already there yeah so if you're someone
that's that way inclined then yeah it
might imply but I think for most people
playing video games is a way to safely
indulge in your fantasies yeah exactly
with corn like you know same thing like
that statistic you you stated it's
almost one in three guys so it's getting
like really high and I think it's it's
like still upward trending right so who
knows where that's going to end but when
a guy can just you know against safely
like go watch corn and deal with that
desire and not have to put himself out
there not get his ego bruise or not face
you know potential legal consequences or
anything like that plus most guys have
no idea what what to do anyways right
and what I've noticed with some of my
clients is guys genuinely will put in
time and effort in some cases money with
a lot of these companies that are
supposed to help them and they still
fail and then they're like well what now
to like rewire your brain chemistry or
something though
like I just don't I don't see a world
where it is a good thing I can't lie I
don't it's not do or die you will you
will survive without thinking
thing but I I wonder if men like the
body because they say that in societies
that um have a large group of sexless
men those men become violent and so I
wonder if
corn helps deter men from being violent
because then they have access to
sexuality in a way these these men they
need good that's what they need Amen to
that I think that's what they need I
think it just
I don't know I just feel like the way
that sex is now is not the same like
people
it's just not like maybe that's what we
love having it intimacy it's just not
about that it's just about getting your
nut in like well but that's why my
question was is sucks a need that men
can't live without
long term
it depends on the generation no I can't
I'm not a man regardless of the jokes no
because it could be someone no that's
not true because there's some men like I
I call I have a great Granddad here and
he he didn't have no kids no he had a
partner for a while but then he went to
the war and he just traveled around the
world and that was his Focus that was
his purpose so I think sometimes they
can shift their purpose I don't know
yeah I think some men are capable a lot
more restraint when it comes
it's just that people don't have the
mental toughness anymore it's like
everything's easy so you can there's no
doesn't have the mental toughness men or
women are one in three women under 30
virgins I haven't no both genders don't
have the mental toughness anymore right
now uh what were you gonna say I was
going to say with your um scenario with
your granddad that could just be like oh
is that out of choice or is it not out
of choice do you know what I mean don't
say a joke though I actually kind of
like yeah do you know that that Tick
Tock when it's like
[Music]
um
I really I I I need to
I need to think about it before
straight that's what I want to say he's
definitely straight but he's like but he
was all into like the um like Wildlife
going for war
he was just out here
but maybe that's his age because he was
like 90 something I don't know it was
the end but I think he wasn't focused on
that men can't ultimately be fulfilled
like I don't need to live without it I
mean it sounds like you know with the
guy kill himself or something like that
but yeah I don't think they can
ultimately be fulfilled because I've had
lots of clients where they have every
area of Life handled I'm sure you've
seen this a lot of times if they don't
have the girl that's like life isn't
complete they're not fulfilled they're
not ultimately happy even if they've got
the money the body like everything they
can have everything going on but without
that partner by their side they're not
ultimately yeah he had a companion for
years but he never like it wasn't that
kind of relationship it was just like a
companion so I think that can be
fulfilled with that loneliness not
necessarily like a sexual drive that can
just be yeah men are not emotional you
think about it
so they can they I don't think they
can't go without sex but they don't need
that romance they don't need that
affection they don't need like we do so
if they want to do whatever they're
doing in the bedroom watching whatever
they want to watch about then they're
happy with it I think I think horns are
really actually I think it's kind of
healthy because I believe like all men
they need sex yeah yeah I agree I think
that they need you know and like
it's good that they at least have corn
you know at least they have that thing
that's like oh cool and it's like what
he does in private at least like oh he
really is I think it's
something natural I think it shouldn't
be like something that you have to be
banged or oh look what these girls are
doing here like okay they chose to do
that they should still work like that so
that's their problems you know don't
look down on that yeah but they're like
um oh because there's type of corn
that's like this there's type of corn
that's like that
they have all the Styles because they
have like a public for all these types
otherwise they wouldn't exist yeah so I
think it's like it's like a necessity
for them but imagine going on your
partner's phone right wow wait wait I'm
curious about it
hear me out here we are cool imagine
going on okay imagine going on your
partner's phone and seeing that they
search for a certain thing so it could
be and it's not me like
thank you
is that an issue for you women
okay I'm not toxic but it's interesting
though is that an issue for women what
they're men
that's why like what would you do if you
saw yourself
with their men engage in with corn yeah
as long as you don't cheat that's and as
long as I don't know if it's scene is
cheating because I'm going to see it
it's cheating I've gotten the other
bunch of the girls here is quaranteeding
yes raise your hand no no
yes yeah you guys say yes
what if what if um so if you think corn
is cheating if you say no to him for sex
can he then go do corn no yeah but
that's not with me but
can we go and just yeah but can he go
and just sleep with anyone else you'd
rather him sleep with someone else I
don't rather him it's it's I'd rather
not know about it and do whatever you
want to do if you're going to sleep with
someone that person you I'd rather you
pay that person and you never cheat on
someone that I personally know so I can
just like at least get to that situation
but I'd rather not know so is it
cheating
but that's why I just it's so
complicated it's not that easy that's
why I really don't want to know are you
okay with that in your relationship what
like cheating as long as you don't as
long as you don't know no
here's the thing about partnership right
because we think boyfriend girlfriend
blah blah blah all of that with time
partnership lasts yeah
your boyfriend you're attracted them
today tomorrow is changing your body is
changing his body partnership and
partnership but that seems like it's 50
okay if you like 50 50 relationships I I
prefer relationships that are a little
bit in more traditional roles where I
can like trust my husband's decisions
you have a Business Partnership and his
is interesting your business was 20
still technically a partner I think for
me partnership just means someone
willing to work with you through the ups
and the Downs through the good and the
bad that's partnership see but
partnership like that it sounds like you
have the same roles and the same input
of decision making where when it's a
husband and a wife that's very clear
it's like different roles yeah like the
man's at the head yeah no yeah but
here's the thing right and I've seen it
happening to my mom what if your your
husband is making the rules today but he
can't make them tomorrow because he's
sick he got a stroke so you have to step
up in his shoes and continue the journey
yeah I mean we're in honor of him that's
partnership I mean we could talk about
exceptions but I'm talking about the
rule which is like most people are I
didn't this is it yeah it's for better
War sickness and health yeah yeah
um to me it's just when you when I hear
partnership it just sounds like 50 50. I
just don't like the word so I just
wonder why it's so common here like I
want a husband I don't want a partner I
think it's just more figure of speech
[Music]
um okay can I ask about the one-sided
yeah yeah okay yeah sure okay so you you
guys do a little bit unconventional of a
relationship right yeah can you tell me
about it so yeah so in the beginning you
know I'll admit it gonna make me sound
like a dick but in the beginning like I
was like seeing girls behind her back
and then eventually we came to terms
with the fact that you know we're just
like what made it work the best was that
I'm just fully upfront and honest about
all of it and then we have like certain
rules so like I don't have girls sleep
over I don't go on dates with girls
um I shower if I see a girl you know I
shower afterwards and stuff like that
um but I'll let you speak to it because
it was like a big process in the
beginning I mean it's definitely not
normal no it was like step by step you
know like
um
like I used to like before I I've always
liked the girl so it wasn't like a big
deal for me like be actually attracted
for girls so and I don't think it was
like a trend like for me at the time
because like I would look different so
uh two girls that's enemy and was like
step by step so first thing like uh
actually we started our relationship
really fast was like we started like
dating for real like in two three weeks
it was like super super fast
and it was like one thing at the time
one time at a time I wasn't like okay
with everything but like I think the way
that we built this thing this like
relationship with a lot of like
um
um like rules like try and air was like
I decided to stay through all of that
and we were really happy now but it was
like of course it's not like she had
never had a threesome it's like about
this prior to prior to dating me she
never had a threesome and now she's had
like over 75 right so like like even
last night right like we we go to the
Ministry of Sound we see a girl we like
and then she approaches the girl likes
us she comes back with us and it's cool
but like it's more just like a fun thing
for us but I also see girls Inside by
myself right but all the like love and
affection and companionship is with her
and other girls are more just for fun
didn't you guys do like you had multiple
girls living in the house yeah yeah in
um we moved two girls in and then we
moved to third girl and we had there was
like some rotating girls in living for
periods of time but at the height of it
there was like three girls besides her
it got to be too much for her and she
left and like I lasted like another week
after that and I just kicked the other
girls out and moved her back in and said
like let's not live with girls anymore I
was gonna ask if how do you not get
jealous because I'm like I would be so
jealous yeah because two of the girls
fell in love with me and it was like a
big it was like it was like non-stop
drama I was trying to basically try what
Hugh Hefner was doing where he was
living with like again the girls next
door and it sounded good Theory but in
practice you know people there's like so
much drama every day about every little
thing so it's like lots of stress lots
of BS like I think the jealous part is
like about like I was okay like living
with the girls but like the part is when
you put a bunch of people together to
live together like the real world kind
of thing it's like it's like those TV
shows like those
um shitty shows you know the people who
started like arguing for nothing it's
like so much drama all the time and what
would like make me like really bad is
like it was like for nothing like for
example
juice and someone said oh but you should
take orange juice and then no no I'm
gonna take out oh my god did you see
that oh my God oh my gosh it's like
everything every little thing is like
you know but the part about me not
getting jealous is because
I don't know I just don't like uh like
my first relationship like I started
like my relationship with when I was 18
it lasts almost three years right and in
the end of like my relationship like I
was with such a nice guy but it was like
truly truly nice you know and I was it
was really really cool and like in the
end of our my relationship with him like
I tried to help him like to be with
other girl you know that was like a
friend of him that he had a crush it
before and she was like really cool she
was like so sweet and I was like no you
guys should be together now you know
and like that thing about jealousy is
something that doesn't bother me so it
was like this because I think it's
natural for the men to have other women
so you you were more annoyed with the
girls in the house you weren't even
jealous no whether it was gel not
jealous but like Superman is like the
amount of that happens every
day for nothing yeah because like are
you like I used to work I was like doing
my like engineer job I'm like civil
engineer I used to work and I would come
back home and they would treat me like
the boss for example all the girls would
come with me with problems and like
scenes like John works a lot I always
took like the part of the house as my
responsibility so I hate for example
imagine like a lamp uh is not working
right it's like I don't I won't even go
to him like to say oh that's not working
let's no I'll go there try to fix when
he has to come to me to say oh that
wasn't work I feel like I failed on that
because like I took that part for me you
know so it was like I would come to the
house and one of the girls oh did you
see that the maid didn't do that oh but
she was supposed to do that and so it
was like dude you could have solved that
while you're making this a thing you
know go there talk to the person talk to
the me like like you don't need me to
like to come to see what's going on and
then I would take one part one side like
oh I think it's better but then the
other part would be like is that is
would you say the culture in Brazil is a
bit different is that much more open
yeah like most girls are bisexual like
most girls are kind of like sexually
liberated
um like we would go out to the clubs
together we'd end up bring home like you
know two other groups of girls a lot of
nights so we had like a stripper pole in
the house so there'd be a lot of nights
where we get back to the house there's
like 10 Brazilian girls like running
around naked in the house I'm like the
only guy yeah I think we have more open
how does it work that way around so if
she brings back a dude well that's not
allowed
I've got a question about this as well
because this is I've never come across
anyone that has this setup
do you think that you're okay with how
you're living because he meets your
other needs like does he meet your needs
emotionally so is that does that make it
okay okay I think that's like when like
what I like when he goes out like to the
other place to bring is like he comes
back happy if he's happy my life like
becomes like
so much easier you know like if it comes
like if he comes back of a smile oh it's
okay I always like well how was your
banking oh it's okay cool nice but like
what Joey says have a nice banging
before I go because I have a second
place now like we were doing like in the
same house and not gonna be too much
like there was literally it was like
quality problems there was like periods
of time when those three girls live in
the house where I was still having other
girls over all the time and the three
girls would like be in their room while
I'd have other girls because they had
like two stars two floors place so it
was like easier because the uh the
upload was like a a setup like with food
nice stuff the the bar you know so it
would like use the other but it's like
was too much of that time so then why
why do you think that you need more
women is it because you can't live
without sex which is what we're no I
just I just like like I devoted my whole
life towards like you know the dating
game and and I just enjoy like going
through the whole process and stuff like
that and if you look like you know back
in history like monogamy isn't natural
anyways it was mostly imposed by by the
church in the state to have familiar
units and stuff like that it's not
natural at all if you look at the animal
kingdom and stuff like that right
there's like a tribal leader like in
monkeys for instance and that sleeps
with all the different females and the
females are all attracted to that tribal
leader but they'll go to other tribes
and try to sleep with the alpha leader
of that tribe right and then they'll be
like fights and stuff but then you think
that's like
a self-esteem thing though because I'm
trying to look at the I'm trying to get
D also you're not monkey because yeah
because I'm thinking because I'm from a
Caribbean culture
and African culture I've got both sides
and I'm telling you right now
I
I no it just could not happen like it
could not happen and I think also in the
UK like what she's saying have you ever
been have you ever been in a
situationship
yeah so you're sharing a guy anyway
without knowing yeah I've been in the
relationship and the man's been for the
streets but yeah no I hear that I hear
that but actually like
would you rather they lie to you and you
just don't know could you be okay with
it if you didn't know
wait no I wouldn't beat up with that
weird person but you wouldn't know yeah
I think what I value most is like the
truth you know yeah it's like the thing
is about to like he can be like sure
like he that he he sits my best my by my
side and he opens his mouth like to tell
me anything he can be sure like the
truth because there's no eyes yeah
because men are gonna do what they want
anyway and that's that's why it's better
for communication which I understand
it's so authentic
I'll tell you something though and I all
due respect to you right but men will
find it at least the men that I'm
surrounded by and I'm 32 and I I I'm
surrounded by loads of men especially
high quality men coaches blah blah blah
but anyway men will find it very
difficult to get married to a prostitute
just because of her work period
and other way around I think woman is
the same right some men will marry a
prostitute but on the promise of like
okay she will change her job blah blah
blah but you will find a very difficult
for a man to settle down with a
prostitute I've dated a lot of strippers
for instance like that they were like
but did you get married to them no but
like I had a lot of stripper girlfriends
in different places yeah girlfriends is
different I wasn't married and having
children
to a stripper or a prostitute now listen
there's there's a lot of prostitutes
that are amazing girls then they're out
there doing that job to support their
families and their circumstances it's
just different better than me 100 now
but they do get pushed down or like not
looked at because they're prostitutes or
strippers it's the same for men the
quality of men and he can make a lot of
money whatever it is wait you think it's
the same for men when they've slept
around when they slept around on openly
sharing about it and it's just everyone
knows about it the quality is
are women skeptical
and reluctant to sleep with Drake
now here is the thing right this is the
thing
um definitely I will just answer your
question it's a No-No right and they're
not yes what about I'm gonna ask you
another what about rappers look at Nick
Cannon and he's got all the babies
who are they going for yeah if they're
going for a certain type of girls that's
like unknown they earn less than them
um they kind of like structure yeah they
will not hesitate in two seconds and and
Drake had a kid with a stripper but high
quality women will definitely not sleep
with Drake and so many other restaurants
you don't have to you don't have to high
quality women like let's say what is but
that's the thing like what is a high
quality I will tell you like I'm sorry
I'm just like people from the parliament
people in the in the in the politicians
they won't do that they don't want them
here's the thing the other man they keep
it low-key you there's a respectful
respect on the name you realize like and
put the respect on my name as well NBA
players have women that like actively
pursue them to the point they'll like
buy hotel rooms like at the places look
to look for where they hang out and also
like know everything about like they
literally personally this is what they
do I'll tell you what they do right
watch out this info because I okay cool
I know I know about this info because I
have personal assist a lot of influences
and some celebs in the UK so I've seen
some behind the scenes of what goes on
and how it works is that
I don't know like an artist or an NBA
player or something I've never worked at
MPP but I'm just saying someone of that
status will go through someone else and
say I'm requesting a girl that's this
age this and this they were Scout for
the girl oh yeah they would say cool
this person
um wants you for the night they require
X Y and Z and that's how it works it's
not even always it wouldn't be just
Drake himself they all do it they all do
it all the contracts there's so many
contracts and that contracts will have
NDA to not mention their name that's
what I'm saying yeah but this is what
I'm saying about it sharing about it
openly does damage your partner name and
their you know quality of who they are
not not necessarily it depends on your
Lane right but if you're going to so
many serious I would say
um position it will impact you you know
I'm not saying man don't cheat to woman
cheat most of the time you don't know
about it and just life keep going on and
you are okay with that right like not
not to like use him as an example but
like if he were to cheat and you didn't
know about it would you be okay with it
would I listen logically right I come
from a culture when Dude okay right I I
would I'll be angry if I knew
I will accept it I have to say there is
so much qualities about my partner if he
done one mistake in so many years I'll
just keep a blind eye I get one pass can
I ask you a question do you feel like do
you feel like you respect your I don't
know how long ago your previous
girlfriends were when he was living
together but did do you think you
respect them the same as you do your now
girlfriend yeah why no equally I heard a
lot more okay
she's like everything I'm looking for
like in terms of you know like she's
very intelligent she's hyper analytical
like me so all these I was like girls
just fun
the ground
oh the the side girls yeah yeah because
I I enjoy going through almost like
someone that got good at chess and it
sounds weird I have one question for you
when you was looking for a wife
did you want to be with someone that was
bisexual to allow those things yes
that's a requirement yeah that was like
your requirement right there's like a
whole list of it has to come from a good
family that's why it works so if you're
happy yeah and I was upfront with it and
she could have left yeah I like the fact
that you're up front with it yeah I
think everyone's relationship is going
to work for them I just wonder how it
would work sorry I'm curious girls who
who would sign up for something like
that okay anyone I personally wouldn't
in that exact dynamic but I would like
to say I respect you so much because you
had to in a way lower your ego to be
able to have him happy if he's happy
then that's what makes you happy and I
feel like in our society now that's
women's problem including myself the
fact that we don't want to lower our ego
in order to make our partner or our
boyfriend or husband happy because we're
always trying to level level up either
be on the same level
it's not like people are in my ego I
don't see it like that I see like I
don't I don't I I'm sorry if I don't
understand you properly but I don't say
this as Larry my ego whatsoever because
it's like I'm seriously okay it's like
because I believe that for men that's my
concept that's my belief I believe for
men like oh no we would like to bingo
bang that makes you happy so go be happy
she's like very selfless as well like
it's not something that's gonna be like
oh my God this is oh you are talking to
no sometimes like like you see a girl
like a beautiful girl walk and say oh my
gosh she's so beautiful it's like I
think sometimes it it's like uh we miss
empathy it's like you know when you go
like to nightclubs and like someone is
like doing bad like he's in a bad moment
I always see like something that I like
to say I always see like girls coming up
to that person say hey dude are you fine
yeah hey can I get you something or or
someone in the bathroom okay you know
and like using that environment because
people are like relax you know and so
when I say like oh go be happy it's not
that I'm trying to like make alarm but
it's like I believe it's like if you're
both like in the same page like what do
you like but you can like do things
together and keep it like easy because I
think like the world outside is already
so hard yeah it's like it's already
gonna try to beat you to meet you so
much if you cannot get home and like be
with a person that like truly like like
understands you like have you by your
side you know it should be like peaceful
it's gonna be really hard you know yeah
I think you can be like more like
empathic like this you know so if he if
he was um banging other girls and
accidentally he maybe got one
impregnated
oh okay 2014. so almost 10 years okay
that solves that problem yeah STDs I
mean everyone you know like most of the
guys I know that I've been you know with
a lot of girls like usually it's like
chlamydia like one to five times or
something I'm not like bragging about it
but like gone in a week with a pill not
that big of a deal I've done videos on
STDs one and two people get that yeah
it's pretty common but like she also
gets like turned on like hearing about
me with girls and she wants to see like
what would the girl look like and stuff
like that
um I I think the way you've gone about
it I say more power to you you know I
think there's a lot of men will be
watching us thinking this guy
found a good one the room that really
the honesty in coming to to terms with
like the rules and stuff like that like
I'm not getting emotionally attached for
these other girls yeah I'm not taking it
how do you stop that though what if you
just meet someone that's incredible and
you no but men can easily detached yeah
no but people think that men don't have
emotions you do what if you just met
something you just thought I just want
to spend time with her more and more
we've had that we've had that happen a
couple times so it has like the Argent
there was an Argentinian girl that was
like she was like Argentinian polish in
Ukraine Ukrainian so like Eastern
European with the South American yeah
she was like great so you fell in love
with her no I didn't fall in love but
like I was like seeing her a bunch and
like she got jealous of Liz because she
liked me a lot yeah the thing is usually
they get jealous of me not me getting
jealous I open my house
it's like you're an account
it's like no not because of this because
I believe like dude if they are both
cool so okay you're very powerful you've
clearly done a hell of a lot of work in
yourself
and then like she got there and I was
like okay like but she knows at the end
of the day like like we have we used to
have like a very loving relationship and
like all the stuff that you'd expect
like from a partner we have all that and
there's like this other thing on the
side but it's not but it doesn't really
detract it's just like something it's a
special circumstance that's my job yeah
I I am so curious though what if she
said a personal trainer started to like
him and she did want to engage with him
what is it about the rules that would
stop you allowing her to be the guy it's
just like 100 off limits for my side but
why
so it is I get it as a Blog
I tell them why I don't want some guy
being my chick yeah I guess I think it's
double standards
yeah I'm wondering okay but even as
women like do you want to bang a bunch
of dudes no no
sometimes it's like I can say like oh
sometimes um like John arrives oh let's
you know let's have sex sometimes I'm
like so tired and it's like
um can you like you know so I I I'm fine
if I say like oh not tonight you know
because I know he's gonna be fine and
I'm not like you know cutting him like
so you know and it's not like something
that's like I feel I need so much
because I'm there's so many activities
that I want to do that's the truth
there's so many things that oh I want to
do that
so when he goes and bangs and like come
back happy it's like oh this is this is
done check so this is fine and then also
I can do my stuff so you have like this
thing together you know like we won't
help each other
like you know when they say activities
they say like stupid like painting
I love painting every guy wants to be
John right now why does he help you so
you help a lot yeah yeah
he is awesome he's like he's really help
you financially yes like I used to have
a job and it was like that thing
um they don't make much of Brazil
right I did a lot of my job seriously I
love my job but the problem is being
inside of my job and having to take care
of like the House John like the dogs it
was like just like too much for me why
because like I would do everything like
kind of and I hate that feeling because
it like really starts to like uh stress
me out so and then he was like dude you
can like do these little things here and
this because it provides you give back
yeah that way exactly like I understand
no yeah so it's like it's it's not hard
privilege yeah it's not it's not like a
hard thing you know babe we need that so
God forbid he lost his job he's gonna
have to get back to monogamy real
quickly
but it's like when I first met him to be
honest like today we have like oh Maids
we have people talk the dogs we have
everything but when I first met him and
you have everything that we can buy it
won't buy and you don't care about so
many uh expensive so for us it's
easy you know like we uh he makes uh
some amount that we don't even have time
to spend like let's say like that so
it's easy it's not like how but like
when I first met him like three years
ago he wasn't rich he didn't have like
that much money and he was like he did
that stuff like we always try to help
and it wasn't like less you have to do
this you have to do no it was like uh I
can do this so you can do that I can do
this you can do that there was a point
that like his company was doing bad and
I was like my job and I was just think
dude if it goes bad
because like he likes some stuff but I
was just saying oh am I able to take us
with my wages for some time and I was to
say okay so I need to work a little bit
more here so I was willing to do that
because like I chose for
it's hot it's like for his mind you know
I think his mind is really fascinating
for me well I found I found that the
girls that say like he has to he has to
earn my submission or he has to make him
a bunch of money they're just keeping
score yeah like relationships aren't
good if you're keeping score of what
he's doing for you and what you're doing
for him yeah
it should be natural
I'm curious from the girls okay would
you rather date a guy you don't all
right this is for a lifetime okay one
guy you don't really like so I don't
know think of the last guy you dated
that you just you're kind of into him
kind of not everyone got someone in
their head okay now now I mean
or the guy you liked the most so the guy
you're the most in love with would do
anything yeah got him in your head now
would you rather share the guy you liked
the most ever and this sort of maybe not
as you know maybe it's not his job to
screw other girls but every now and then
he's gonna get some strange but you're
the main you're the main
or stay with the guy that you eh kind of
liked for life kind of like kind of kind
of like kind of liked
can I just say something I won't share
the guy that I like the most but I'll
share the guide that I don't like the
most so if I like you that much I want
you to be mine if I don't like you I'm
happy to yeah if you provide for me we
have an agreement there you go go do
whatever you want I don't give two F's
okay what about you I mean I'd rather
just stay single but if I had to pick
one it'd probably be the guy that I
don't really like because if I really
like someone I am jealous and I am Petty
as well and I will do the most if I like
you and you're not mine do you know what
I'm saying
okay what about you it's a difficult one
because if you're living with someone
that you don't like you're going to be
very miserable and very unhappy so would
you rather just build yourself to a
confidence where you don't mind and like
I see she's so confident and she's happy
I would rather be with someone that I
love and be happy so but but my do you
guys think that most men cheat or no
yeah yeah depends where you come get him
so why would it be different with you
like in your case would be like oh my
guy wants it's gonna change for me it's
the same thing it's just the respect you
know I definitely it's the respect I
salute you so and I think you're like I
can sense you guys are both are great
people you know and you're like really
subtle sure of you who you are and it
takes a lot of work to do that but there
is also a red line I think that just
boundaries if you want to create
children healthy relationship because
it's easier you have to work way harder
than I have to work I'm like I know my
boundaries he knows his boundaries
things might slip out of balance with
just like forgive forget blah blah blah
work them out but the work that you both
have to do and maybe you're naturally
ignite can sense that you naturally are
not jealous person you know you
naturally are way more open-minded than
a lot of women but she must have met him
doing that yes but I think also in the
future when you have kids things might
get out of balance it's harder work I
think you know if you just see
relationship traditional relationship
the most successful relationship was
just stay with your woman if you cheated
don't ever let her know same if she if
she I tried that I tried at the
beginning right yeah and there was like
times where like she came over and like
there was she came over early or maybe
not even early but I was like sloppy and
she like arrived and I was with a girl
yeah and it's like giant fight right but
we keep we keep like the emotional stuff
like segmented yeah like the love and
the affectional stuff just with her yeah
I don't know about how much longer the
world will be normal but no I mean we're
pretty happy with the three dogs we have
it still allows flexibility to travel
and do all this yeah it's interesting
I'm curious
ly older there's there could reduce of
your sexual needs you probably won't
even need to have as much
but I take like supplemental
testosterone through an endocrinologist
I still take like Maca and the different
libido supplements my point is if that
is what brings you fulfillment right
right now at this point what would bring
you the film in the future
I don't know I mean like I come from an
interesting background like the reason
why I went and slept with 1600 girls I
came from like a pretty verbal abusive
childhood where my parents really nice
people but they're always saying like
you're going to be nothing you're going
to be a failure you're going to be this
like that and when I like sleep with a
new girl it makes me like feel like oh
I'm not like that yeah
and then a little bit there I don't know
if it's compensating but it's it's
definitely like but you know I wouldn't
have gone and done this had I not come
from that background like people like a
lot of like the best UFC fighters
they're bullied for instance as a kid
and they were like I'm gonna become the
best fighter in the world so like I
think my mom like stripped all the like
validation for me like routinely over
over you come back is to sleep with
women too make up for that trauma yeah
what would you all right cool I'm a
client I'm a guy I come to you and I say
to you right I sleep with
I don't know eight women a week right
I've been doing it for years years but
now I'm ready to commit to one woman
what advice would you give me
if you want to go from from seeing a
bunch of people just to one because
that's obviously helping me that's
helping my confidence and that's
fulfilling so how would you say to me
cool
stop that stick to one woman and this is
how you can what why wouldn't I don't I
don't ever tell them like you know you
should just be doing this but you know I
don't tell them like any societal
narratives I don't tell guys to get a
girlfriend or wife or bang a bunch of
girls or see a bunch of girls I want to
be with one woman how can I go about
that would you even give them advice
lots of lots of guys just want
girlfriends but but most of them like in
practice like once I teach them to be
able to have a bunch of options and they
pick the best one usually and get more
serious with that one but you know if
they had that issue where they were
seeing a bunch
I would you know they have to like
realign their internal values and stuff
like that I guess but they wouldn't even
want to do that I don't think do you
guys who here out of the women thinks
that all men cheat when given the chance
you know what I would have to say I
discovered something new tonight
completely because she's stunning
gorgeous right and a lot of women that
get cheated on they will just say
I'm out of shape I'm I'm less but it's
just I'm realizing your looks and who
you are won't stop men cheating and
wanting tips I want to just get this all
right you think yes I hope raise your
hand if you think yes all men cheat when
given the chance
yeah okay so
um three girls I'm just curious so NBA
players have women and I know this um I
just interviewed a guy who he has like
good friends with a couple professional
sports players right and he said that on
the sidelines these girls
that are tens okay nines and tens will
come to their games and just offer them
threesomes and say like we're available
and they hunt them down and try to get
them to cheat on their wives
uh what do you what do you guys do you
think those guys Mo that most guys would
cheat in that situation
if he's a man of God then it's very
unlikely
as well the fear of hell right no no
it's not
it's not it's not fear of hell I think
men and women
men and women yeah of course I think
that's delusional honestly I know some
pretty religious dudes but like it's
very unlikely but if you tell me a 10
like most of these religious guys would
say they would never do it have never
been enough wait can I just say yeah
also just because someone says they are
religious does not mean they are
religious someone can say they are 10
out of 10 religious like you said you
know religious people but that doesn't
actually mean a religious thing where
you can go to church doesn't mean you're
a Christian just because you go to
church what is religious
I think that's so relevant it's
different for everyone it could me
personally I can't say because I'm
actually not religious but I could ask
you and I could ask you and you could
both give me two completely different
answers that could both be correct but
but I'm saying my point is even
religious guys if they're in if they're
in a situation where tens are hunting
them down
they're gonna religious I read religious
people are more likely to commit rape
normal yeah great great that's the word
I was looking for then actually normal
dudes that's a statistical fact though
I've read that before a statistical one
well I don't know about that but all I
know is that because they're
like well
um we had a conversation before about
church guys and dating Church guys or
people that are religious because
they're around such like Purity for that
it's like that's like another world like
oh I want to try that yeah look at the
priests right in the Catholic Church
exactly that yeah I think religion is no
guarantee for not cheating yeah at all
um I'm not it's less likely though I'm
gonna take a second to read Super Chat
um guys make sure you like the video
um And subscribe to the Channel all
right black is Panther if you're looking
for someone to make you happy then you
will die alone find someone you're happy
being with like this couple happiness is
a choice a marriage politics and short
uh Sports women need to stop the cat
projection
um women cheat as much or more than men
uh marriage politics and sports um Pearl
on the steps of the vetting process for
men is whether sex with your woman will
always stay transactional or and never
becomes validational guys should never
marry a woman like that a Dion C it's
easier to hire an escort and a chef than
have a modern day girlfriend or partner
probably cheaper black Moses ask the
panel what violent video game dictators
played from the 1920s 30s 40s 50s and
60s to make them violent John
Argentinian uh
[Music]
where for the parade of ism it is a
hundred percent seated by the elites
through mainstream media through think
tanks ngos and universities divide and
conquer baby John Argentina its divide
and Rule is top down not Grassroots D
currently away with uni students a girl
accused Five Guys of grape this week
even though CCTV footage showed
otherwise she was a willing participant
kiwi any advice for a Christian dude
with two kids in a sexless marriage I'm
going on for years now answer that for a
sexist marriage I'm very big on like
authenticity and just having like
straight up conversations with people
right so he should just say like hey I
don't like this what's what's the
problem here and find out where that's
coming from and try to work it out
together like to adults right and I
think that's the best what if she still
doesn't sleep with him then what uh that
depends on his own values right we need
to have to realize he'd have to come up
with you know is this important enough
to leave the girl or not that depends on
the guy's own values but he should find
out at least where it's coming from if
it's like a power play or something like
that I mean that's that could signal
other problems but
okay there's no there's no black and
white answer to that I don't think
um Isaac social interactions in person
where boys learn the skills to interact
with people are being replaced by social
media so the ones that are already timid
are being left behind um 110 Shamir lady
with the vest if a bird had your brain
it would fly backwards
um
today let me just refresh this real
quick D
um Church girls are the worst 304s um
the church is not pure anymore
um black is I read that one already okay
so question
how can single men overcome anxiety or
fear of rejection in the dating world
I'll answer that one yeah I literally I
think single men need to actually
partner with other men men like myself
men like yourself and actually learn
from other men and I think they need to
get to the bottom of why that's
happening with they need to do with
their own mindset
it's literally because it's rejection
right he said for me rejection is all
about what you make it mean it's not the
rejection it's the meaning that you
subscribe to that rejection what do you
make that mean I'm not good enough I'm
not tall enough I'm not rich enough as
opposed to just one person so it's
really it's cultivating an abundant
mindset there are so many women and
great people out there and once you've
got an abundant mindset it's a bit like
I don't know it's like I don't know it's
like I don't know going to McDonald's
and they run out of your burger do you
get upset by it you go and find another
one isn't it right or you missed the bus
you wait for another one why is it when
it comes down for human beings we feel
oh my God that's rejected it's just okay
one person rejected you now if you're
really clever you might find that why
that might be somewhere to start if
you're courageous enough why did you
reject me go and catch a person you're
too short or you're this or your breath
things whatever find out whatever it is
be be courageous they're too short
there's nothing you can do about it so
have the courage to accept things you
can't change that's fine but there are
plenty of very confident charismatic
short guys out there getting women so
it's not the short thing it's it's who
you're being you know what's interesting
just being social media and like having
people mess it like you know sometimes I
do one-on-ones or sometimes people
message me with like problems or
whatever I found that men are so much
more willing to take feedback than women
true where it's like if a woman if you
even imply it's something with her for
the reason that she's single it's like
all hell breaks loose like I always say
this like if you're single the men you
want don't want you yeah because if the
men you want want to do you'd be with
them yeah and but it's like somehow
that's offensive just like the same way
that if if the girls like if you're not
having sex like the women you want
aren't sleeping with you yeah and it's
it's it's it's it's but the thing is
though even though I think women are
much more likely to do a lot of
self-development work on themselves oh I
disagree from what I've seen a lot of
men
if there's a crisis women's
self-development is this it's journaling
it's plastic surgery
um it's healing which never includes
actual therapy and if it does it's
short-lived and not consistent I
vehemently
engage in it more men are a lot more
stubbornness in my in terms of coaching
men men tend to be a lot more stubborn
but I think they're a lot more realistic
I think sometimes women can be a lot
more deluded about the actual real world
so taking all this action but it may not
like you said like let me look at myself
men tend to be a lot more stubborn
though about doing that work for
themselves that's the difference I think
if both can tweak it women need to be a
lot more realistic about the world
you're right if you're not getting
guides you want you need to look at
yourself it's not the men you need and
it's not it's okay whereas men tend to
do it after the horse is bolted you know
men will do it after say the marriage is
failed or after something's gone wrong
then they start looking that's it that's
what I mean like when when I have men
like ask me about you know whatever DM
me message me and if I give them advice
like they'll come back within a month or
two months later and have actually
improved where it's like women it's just
not the same they I never they do but
look at the stats with men though you
know the statue of men are getting worse
you know one-third of men I think it's
just five and six men are being divorced
I think it's because men just don't
think the juice is worth the squeeze
anymore it's like it's like they do all
this and what do they get on the other
side if mentor on mass they would change
the world that's what men don't get but
men truly demanded a certain level of
behavior they'll change you but men are
falling for the first trap they're
hitting up these girls with likes and
they're telling women they're amazing
actually creating the very well what I'm
saying that they compare it starts it
the women start it because they start
with the Thirsty I don't see a second I
didn't sorry to interrupt you by the way
I don't see it as men against women I'm
just saying what kind of world do you
want to create as your action in
alignment with the world you want to
create but my point is that like I think
the women need to start before the man
but what if they don't then what are you
gonna do I mean I think like it's gonna
more and more men are gonna be sexless
and I think I think it's actually going
to be in a world where there's more
relationships like this to be honest
no no but statistically there can only
be a few of you that do yeah the stats
won't eat but that's the point is that
more and more men will be sexless the
trend is heading that way so what does
that mean the rest of us I think more
and more women will be childless I think
50 probably yeah number 30 will be
single and childless and that's what so
I think if women don't improve that's
the future that we're going to see I
wanted to comment on the the rejection
thing so like what I found over 10 years
of coaching and stuff now is that most
guys have this unrealistic expectation
that they want every girl to like them
so I tell them like if you were cold
calling in sales or you were knocking
doors it doesn't matter if you're the
best salesman in the world you're going
to encounter people that just tell you
to off or they're going to tell you
I'm not interested and a lot of those
things are outside of your control like
there exists girls that have boyfriends
and husbands that don't want to cheat
when you talk to them in the club
there's girls that are in a bad mood
they don't like you for whatever reason
instead of taking that personally and
thinking I suck think okay that one's
just not interested this one probably
will but most men get deflated and then
they bring that negative energy into the
next interaction and then that causes
them to get rejected with a higher it
would be hard not to I mean I worked in
sales I sold copiers and I'm telling you
there's nothing worse than selling it
you know it's like to sell like a
stand-up ten thousand dollar copy
machine
who wants that and I'm like I I can't
even imagine because when I did that job
it was so soul-sucking yeah that I'm
like go getting rejected and that
contributes to the problem right because
the guys have to develop almost like an
emotional resilience yeah yeah you have
to or you just have like this thick skin
and you just know that when you hit
those girls that are interested there's
going to be other girls that are
interested and but a lot of guys will
take it personally I get clients they'll
go up get two or three rejections and
then just give up and they stop
approaching for the night so what's
what's your advice to men that want to
overcome their fear of rejection well I
tell them to follow uh the old school
three second rule right so you have less
than three seconds to go in once you see
the attractive girl and then assume it's
going to go well and if it doesn't don't
take it personally and I I give them
strategies for how to open properly
right like with direct eye contact
speaking loud enough smiling Etc versus
like coming in Meek and passive and this
and that so I give them chances to give
or give them strategies give them the
best chances but then also be realistic
about the fact that it's not going to
work out with some girls no matter how
good you get no matter how high value
get anything there's still gonna be
girls who don't like you and there's
coaches that are like when you get good
enough there's no more rejections that's
false or they're you're never gonna get
flaked on a date it's like really people
don't have things come up with their
schedule so these are just part of the
game people have to be able to just deal
with those things and not take it super
personally what about the ladies what's
your advice that to men that want to
overcome their fear of rejection I
haven't heard too much from you
okay I want to hear from these three
first I feel like the more that you do
something the more confidence you'll
have when you do it like rejection is
not always rejection I like the phrase
rejections redirection so it's like just
do it there's a quote I don't know what
it's like it's like confidence is the
amount of times you do something okay or
something like that basically just do it
just try to put yourself out there
what's a good opening line and I want
the guys to say if you think these are
good that a guy should use to a girl I
want the dating coaches to read it
oh see I don't know I don't have words
like that I like
I'm joking
um I like winter grasses
um
um okay I like gonna go says Hey excuse
me you're looking really beautiful today
um or say hi um how are you did it like
something like that I don't know I like
I like it to be complimented like oh oh
do you need help with it I don't know if
they see me doing something oh oh what
are you doing here today I don't know
like nice not like
forward like so the good opening line is
high you look very beautiful today how
are you yeah yeah no no how you look
very beautiful today like like what's
your name like where are you from like
oh do you mind if I could um
good or bad uh it depends on like you
know if he's like kissing your ass or
like supplicating their debt but if it's
just like a nice comment that's fine
yeah yeah now that you ask me I think
I'm part of the problem that we're
talking about because if a guy was to
move to him on the street I wouldn't
take him seriously for sure that's the
thing yeah I think I would just assume
that he does that with everyone but he's
single so yeah
he wouldn't say the higher you're
beautiful
okay okay so you think it's cringe you
think it's okay it depends I mean like
those like London digging guys were like
hello I thought you're hot and like that
and they're just doing that like in Mass
right yeah that's why he said it depends
on how you say it that's a nice thing my
opener for 10 years just been I want to
meet you real quick it's like very
direct I wanted to meet you and you say
like when they're like okay yeah yes
that's that's the way but I hope
pedestal oh my God you'll be for how
many times has she had that no no like
that but like you're putting it on a
kind of level of oh my God you're so
beautiful I'm not used to now because
hey how's it going what's your name
how's it going it depends on the frame
of how it comes across like you don't
want a guy that comes up wow you're like
the most amazing you don't want that
just like oh I just saw you like I
thought you look really beautiful like
you know what are you doing around here
like what are you doing today I like
that kind of thing
what's your advice to you guys and
what's your opening line My love
language My love language is acts of
service so if it's something very simple
as let me get that for you as he's
opening the doors my knees start to go
weak or even yeah or even at the bars
like let me get that for you I'm just
like okay all right it's like uh Jay
Waller he says don't open doors for
girls
I still believe in that
um but also with me I'm very I'm a
person that's very aware and I also know
that rejection is very hard so if a guy
does take does approach me I know it's
taken him a lot to be able to do that so
I'm not going to reject him and be rude
and say oh I'm not interested I'm gonna
go with the flow of the conversation and
I'll let him down gently but I think it
also what you were saying that you're
the problem it takes us to be as human
beings to be empathetic as well to
understand that he's still a human he
does still have feelings it has taken a
lot for him to approach you so just be
nice yeah for sure so what do you think
of her I like that that's quite natural
isn't let me get the door for hey where
are you off to yeah your name how's it
going yeah
I don't know
you cannot be I don't like anything
that's like all like contrived and I
mean that's not gonna even happen that
often right like in terms of like
situation depending
I mean I think just starting the
conversation being direct as long as
there's not like fancy gaming gimmicky
stuff then that's thumbs up for me okay
what about you what's your advice to men
what's a pickup line that you like
the thick pickup line but I'd say be
confident not arrogant and be just be
straightforward what's the difference
between confidence and arrogance well I
feel like in the context that working
here
I feel like with the context that we're
talking about you don't want to come off
as I know I'm coming to get you and I'm
getting you and I'm I've got you do you
get one do you know what I'm doing
confidence
I think confidence is I don't mind
getting rejected but if you reject me
I'll walk off like a man and I won't oh
you're dead anyway or you know oh that's
the worst of a guy yes mad yeah okay
thing though yeah like for example no
yeah that's that just to use it that
happens in sales too right I don't know
if you saw that in sales but I did sales
for a summer to see how it translates to
game and there's like rookies that go up
the door and they the guy slams the door
on their face and they're like yelling
stuff at the guy or it's like a veteran
who's like okay that person is not
interested and they don't take it
personally yeah versus like trying to
get even no in the UK guys take it
personally they'll be like oh you're
ugly anyway
but that's young guys yeah
if I did that comment I just like here
and there yeah yeah yeah I know it
depends
um so did you have a line or no I don't
have a line but I'd say me personally I
like it when a guy starts off with a
compliment but not an obvious compliment
not anything to do with my face whether
it be something about my style or the
way I carry myself oh so if a guy
compliments your style yeah something
yeah good or bad
that's good yeah that's cool okay uh
what about you yeah I usually like I
started complimenting this style or
something that because like if I'm
approach a person like uh for sure it's
because there's something that I'm
interested in that person
oh I think you're really cool yeah like
you see me really cool what's your name
oh can you talk oh let's think fun facts
okay that's a compliment though yeah do
you like that one yeah I mean as long as
it got like the biggest problem I've
seen is that like a lot of coaches say
like come in and say oh you look like
you like this or like you know just say
really cheesy fancy gimmicky stuff where
they're like using lines or like you
know these these clever pickup lines or
like different stuff like that and that
just has like this air of like this is a
a little tactic that I'm trying to win
you over with yeah like all the common
theme between all the responses is they
want the guy to be like genuine and
actually like showing that he's
interested without hiding it right like
guys that come up and ask you for
directions like it's obvious that they
don't want directions yeah but like you
like lose maybe a little respect because
he's not having the balls to be
straightforward and that's the iron if
you think about it you only get good at
that if you deal with rejection right
because it's almost the emotional
calibration and you have to deal with
the rejection to get that inward that
didn't work well that didn't work with
that type of woman so you have to do it
in order to have the hey how's it going
how are you doing that's the beauty of
rejection what's your line
my line oh
um
yo what's happening
every London guy ever no is that what he
said pretty much I did I did yeah yeah I
have to own that but also I want you
approached him yeah okay how what line
did you use
it wasn't really a line it was an
ultimatum a little bit if you don't want
me there's lots of men doing she really
played the kind of manipulation with it
we were good friends for a long time
though to be honest I've seen him did
your friend zone him or did she friend
zone you no no one friends only travel
when I first saw I was in a relationship
so and then we just became friends we
were doing a lot of the same coaching
and self-development together and then
when I got single she kind of did the
ultimatum look you better take me now
because you don't someone else will want
me
you know but for the minute I first saw
it it was just like love at first time
but I wasn't a relationship that's crazy
no I didn't he did the girl because of
her it just didn't work out well yeah
dump her if it was I thought it was
right because
where I met at the context I met her we
were doing a lot of self-development
training a massive um self-development
country
um uh company and integrity was a very
important thing in terms of the training
we were doing and I had to learn that
because I've come from a culture of just
chatting up girls willy-nilly right but
I still never really believe in cheating
necessarily I'm avoids because my
parents have been married for 60 plus
years I've always believed that monogamy
the rest of it but from an Integrity
point of view I was already in a
relationship so straight away I'm not
gonna even go there I could acknowledge
oh my God she's beautiful that's exactly
the kind of woman I want to be with but
because of my situation I was like I'm
not going anywhere near there and when
it naturally ended and I was single and
we were friends for ages she then made
the move and I was like hell yeah I'm up
for it because for a minute I met you
you were perfect you know Fair woman
yeah I don't know I don't know what to
feel about that I don't know whether to
be like
respect or be like the iris but what if
it worked out with the girl you're in
the relationship with yeah I've never
got into a relationship with him you'd
have been in love she was an opportunist
that's not it's not a bad thing I own my
action I've seen that guy and there's a
lot of values that he have that I value
now here's the thing right even though
he was in a relationship I didn't really
interfere at all we were friends we'd
probably chat once every now and then
now when he was uh not in that
relationship I was not his type anymore
because when he met me I was the perfect
size you know I was the perfect look I
lost it I had to work my you know self
to be that person and that's nothing I
own who I am you know I mean I know
exactly what I want and if there is an
opportunity of course I'm gonna go for
it you know there's no shame about it
yeah go for what you want yeah yeah and
my dreams yeah and my advice for guys
because I know that's the question is
don't listen to women they most of the
time they don't know personally I don't
know what I want from a man go and find
someone that inspires you a man that
really have that perfect relationship
there's so many coaches out there
coaching you about relationship but
they're not go and find a relationship
that inspires you and get his advice he
will be able to open his heart and share
his advice with you so question for the
women have you ever approached a guy
and have you ever been rejected
no yes yes yeah oh cool okay tell me
tell me about it as approach but not
being rejected oh you've never been
rejected you have you approached yeah
have you been rejected yeah what
happened
um it's just when I open up and say what
I want for my future and what I like for
example that I want to be married and I
want to have family they tend to be like
you said that immediately yeah okay yeah
okay I'm I'm pretend I'm the guy not a
bar and say oh I want to get married
like on the first date or something like
that yeah on the first day I'm talking
about like approaching a guy like cold
approach oh no no no no never have you
ever cold approached uh I think I have
at a bar at a club yeah they're always
into it yeah okay what about you have
you ever called approach no no no have
you ever caught a privilege
I don't think so no that's interesting
right I would know I don't know I don't
think so no I have yeah
no never yeah
and what about you have you ever
approached a guy yeah were you ever
rejected yes really yeah how what do you
say
um I remember like once I was like in
the grocery there was this really hot
guy like it was like John like exactly
no she was like my type like this and
then I was like oh my God but I was like
you know it was like civil engineer work
in a site construction so well like
almost like the majority of my time I
wasn't like dressed up I wasn't like
cute it was like with boots like jeans
like you know
and now I kick him up to him and he said
oh I'm sorry I'm married and I said okay
he's married that's good yeah
and I think like when I was younger too
like I I don't know I think getting
rejected is like part of life yeah
I'm curious from the guys is there a
rejection that was like your worst
rejection that you can think of well
I've called approach like probably tens
of thousands of times but you know every
now and then there'll be a girl that
just tells you to off or like tries
to insult you personally or something
like that and that that can hurt
sometimes right you get over that like
you just you just learn that's gonna
happen sometimes but especially for like
clients that aren't used to approaching
if they hear something that early on
where the person says like oh no I don't
like you because of this and this that
sticks in their head and they think
every girl thinks that and it can be
like debilitating and I can take them
out of the game I think for me the the
worst approach
um rejections I can remember is when
they don't say anything they pretend
they don't hear you no they look at you
like how dare you even think you have
what it takes to come up to me and I
don't say it's just everything in the
eyes is saying that and you feel like
some girlfriend they don't hear you too
like they just stand there but it'd be
nice if they're pretending they don't
think about the ones that hurt you
I mean I was insulted that you come up
to them that happened to me to me like
two days ago with the girl okay I I just
was complimenting her outfit I was like
oh my gosh that's so cute she just
looked at me no and I know she's I know
she heard me and then she just like kept
like because I was sitting at like a
table bar you know what I mean and she
just kept she just like looked the other
way okay then then I go to this other
place right and she's there and then she
she starts talking to me and she's like
can you take my Instagram picture I'm
like
it becomes almost like funny though like
in the beginning like if a girl would
ignore I'd be like oh my God like I'm
horrible yeah but now like if I go to a
bar and I'm like okay I want to meet you
real quick and the girl's like pretend
she's in here I'll be like and I know
you hear me can I just talk to her a sec
if they're still not responsive then
I'll just walk you know just walk away
right away but it doesn't even register
you get to the point I mean if I was
single as well it's like you just don't
care yeah but it's almost like it's
almost like funny too you're like look
at this like what the okay the chat
is saying tell me you didn't take her
picture I did I'm not even going
[Music]
just like is this what men go through
like that that is what they're good for
yeah
that's what I go for I feel like I'm
apart
a minute of a lifetime for so many years
yeah yeah I was like I don't like this
look at that woman that became a man for
a bit wasn't it the story where she
became a masturbate she committed
suicide on the life the surface they say
yeah which was only a man for a short
time well I don't think most women
aren't like I don't think we really
noticed the privilege we're given in
society just from being young women
where we're like treated better by
people and the first time this happened
to me I am I worked in a sales job and I
was the only girl in the office and
people would always help me with
whatever I wanted you know what I mean
yeah and all the guys around me would be
like oh it's because you're a girl it's
because you're a girl and I was like no
it's because I'm so bubbly and I work
hard
yeah okay yeah and then I found out it
was in fact because I was a girl because
I feel like you're not even in like a
romantic way but I think that men just
have more of an inclination to like help
yeah yeah
it's more fun than helping a guy yeah
yeah even if it's not like it also goes
the other way though because then
there's also a sense of not taking women
as seriously as well so it flips doesn't
it I've never had like I've never felt
that was an issue to be honest and I've
worked in like predominantly male
dominated Fields I think it's an
advantage not a disadvantage yeah but I
think you've probably learned how to you
know your powerful Mercy you've learned
how to I'm the same I will always
navigate whatever you know limitations
Society based on Me based as a black man
for instance I don't care yeah some
people don't learn that skill so they
actually internalize no I'm not enough
it's an excuse I think there's zero
limitations as a woman like zero none
unless it's like a strength I agree I'm
gonna lie yeah I feel like the girls
that whine about going to corporate and
having a hard time like I just think
it's an excuse they're just big whiners
I don't think so Pearl I have to say
there is there is a listen there's women
do get treated by compassion people help
them out but there's also the view of
like oh women is weaker than a man and
there's nothing wrong with that logic
like physically woman is weaker than a
man but if a woman's trying to get some
level of finances or authority she will
definitely get a backlash of like you're
a woman I disagree I think there's quote
there's quotas for women I think women
get put in positions they shouldn't be
in all the time what do you mean like I
feel like women get put in positions
they're actually not qualified for and
they're not the best person for the job
because of quotas and diversity Hunters
yeah some some um
where women or people of color do have
to prove themselves more in order to be
getting taken seriously no so I just
think as for women in my experience I
don't think there's any disadvantage and
most of the girl as I know that complain
about it are just kind of lazy to be
honest I don't agree with you pero I get
you but I don't agree with you given
that I'm with my partner and sometimes I
go for what he's going for I put my
hands up I don't speak as perfect
English and I'm not intelligent as much
as he is but there's a lot of positions
that he gets picked when I don't you
know maybe he's just better he is
unfortunately yes that's right but
there's sometimes when they give him
chances but give me a chance to just
prove that I'm better or maybe I'm equal
in some there is a lot of places that
I'm quite equal but I feel like it's
like a mindset thing like if I if I get
passed up for a job with a dude like I'm
not gonna think it's because of my
gender I'm thinking I'm gonna think it's
because I'm not good enough yeah but
that's what I mean there's two different
things at play one there is and a
disadvantage for some people in society
whether it's based on your race whatever
it might be even height they've showed
studies about that but I think the
second thing is who are you in the face
of that and that's what you're alluding
to yeah so I don't care there are times
of course I mean I've grown up as a
young black boy how many times I've got
stopped police of course statistically I
knew there was more I have friends that
would walk around with whatever in their
pocket they never get stopped as I do I
get it it's a reality but my thing is
who are you going to be in the face of
it that's the difference so I recognize
that Society does treat different people
differently that's that's just true but
my thing is I don't do the victim thing
because of it and I think that's what
you're talking about you're not a victim
in fact I actually turn on his head
because it happened I'm gonna go even
harder that's it you know I was brought
up toad you're black you're gonna have
to work three times
yeah I'm not gonna complain no why do I
have to work three times
and it's given me an advantage
disadvantage gives you an advantage you
see it with like rappers now they're
hungry get the way they come from they
mean it when they say get rich or die
trying so there are discrimination
against them but it makes them what I
don't like is victim culture but I just
I think that Society openly
discriminates against men way more than
women and that like and I I think if
that wasn't the case like there wouldn't
be quotas in these jobs yeah like I
think people want women in leadership
positions because in a lot of companies
they have diversity hires true but
that's a quite a recent thing I would
say probably isn't in the last
generation I mean it's been implemented
since like the 60s at least in the US
since the 60s yeah last animation or two
yeah but that's I mean I'm 26 so that's
two of two two of my lifetimes that's
quite a long time to me
it's the pendulum thing isn't it I think
it's song too far now it still sounds
like let's get someone diverse in there
even though then I mean I think about oh
it's bad that I say about our Chancellor
of course an absolute nightmare I wonder
if he was thrust in that position next
thing you know he had the most terrible
him in the prime minister is trust you
know that's an example I think where
people just put into position because
they can agreement
swinging I actually don't really see it
like women were discriminated against
like ever because I just think that we
had different roles like we could say
that men were discriminated against
because they had to go to war we didn't
have to go I don't think I think Society
was set up differently I don't think
it's discrimination in that I mean give
an example for instance right if it
wasn't for the fact that men went to war
women would never been allowed in these
industrial jobs it's not discrimination
it's just a limitation based on an
assumption of your woman you can't do it
strength you know or you're black you
can't do it well I mean I think when it
comes to war like we can't
now but when it did women did fill the
positions that men left behind I was
talking about war oh actually I mean me
and you could fight you're even if I'm
the strongest woman you're gonna win
physically yeah I mean there are some
female climbers out there that runs
around something if women were doing so
well in the military they wouldn't
continually lower the requirements for
them
it's true like they literally had to
lower the requirement for us to become a
seal I think when it's physically like
that but definitely in society there
have been instances where people have
not been given a chance because of an
assumption about what they were capable
of and when they were given that chance
you could see that they excelled I mean
as a time the NBA wasn't full of black
players you know there were times for
answer we've got a friend who's um a
black um football agent there was a time
that was unheard of the other time when
women weren't seen able to run a
football club and yeah I'm just talking
about gender yeah so my what I was
talking about was when I just don't
think women were ever really
discriminated against I think Society
was different
what's the definition of discrimination
about like earning differentials right
even in the modern days because of their
gender isn't it really is well I come
from a culture when it's the opposite to
the West right now women do get abused I
was about to say these are the people
that I know personally the man will
cheat she can't say any word and she
will get hit and there's no one's gonna
stand for her she goes to play her
parents stay in that marriage you've got
kids and you're not coming back to us
I'm talking about in the west I don't
know what but that's what I'm saying we
could do different right that's what he
says it's been shifted right so there's
a lot of women right happen because of
that because it that was like 100 years
ago here so the woman stood and raised
their voice but it became quite toxic
right now and I think what's really
missing is balance yeah that's possible
yeah there definitely was a time when
women were discriminated it's happening
just along and gender lines on class
lines the other time for instance
working class guys couldn't vote so
there's always been a sense where
power's been concentrated in the hands
of whatever privilege it was and that
the other had to fight for that oh they
can actually that's my point is like it
wasn't it was about like roles and
responsibilities like it wasn't just
open discrimination but I mean it was
but it wasn't like for example like they
always talk about how women couldn't
vote but the majority of women didn't
want to vote like if they asked them
they pulled them and the majority of
women didn't want to vote because it
came with being drafted and so how it's
it's not really discrimination it's
roles and responsibilities where the men
were responsible for protecting where
the women were responsible for staying
out but before women got their suffrage
wasn't it the case that men who were
fighting also didn't weren't didn't have
a chance to vote so the majority of
people didn't have the chance but I
don't remember exactly how it was
structured it's been it's been a bit
since I've looked at it but like I
actually because there was always this
narrative that like women were oppressed
and put down and that's always what I
thought until I found out I started
researching the anti-suffragettes or
whatever they were called and they're
basically like women that were against
women voting and I was like why on Earth
would women not want the right to vote
and it turned out it was because it came
with the responsibility because when you
think about it you're voting at least in
the U.S for the commander-in-chief so
that's the person that's in charge of
the army so it kind of makes sense for
you to have some skin in the game but
you don't think that historically women
weren't discriminated against and you
know
forget like even War but you say women
authors had to come out as men in order
to be taken seriously women
photographers had to pretend there were
men in order to be taken seriously
they've been time and time again
instances in in society where women had
to pretend to be men in order to be
taken seriously I mean same with the
first female doctor I believe it was in
France I think if you had to pick women
by and large being discriminated against
in men by and large being discriminated
against I would say men were
discriminated against more
men and women I'm just because then it
becomes our men have had it worse than
women and it becomes this battle I'm
talking just purely in terms of you know
women discriminate against and so with
men has there ever been discrimination
ever sure but do I do I think it's like
this narrative that by and large like
women had such a horrible life and were
oppressed and all of this stuff yeah no
I I agree with you I think that's been
fanned by certain elements of third wave
and fourth and fifth waves of feminism
that's true but definitely historically
women have definitely been discriminated
and so have many men I really think that
feminism it's all the same wave um I
think it is it and always has been a
hate group
because it started in 1888 in Seneca
Falls New York
um and the first anti-suffragettes they
planned assassinations
um they yeah people don't realize that
yeah people like they weren't this like
peaceful group that people think about
um so yeah I think it's always been the
same movement which is freedom we want
the freedom without the responsibility
and it started with the right to vote
because they wanted the freedom of
voting without the responsibility of
having any skin in the game and I think
it always started with wanting to
destruct the family because if you look
at the anti-suffragettes um which like
if you look at their writings about why
they didn't want to vote they would talk
about how
um this was the beginning of the
destruction of the family because before
then you trusted your husband um you
trusted his leadership and so that it
was in they're right it was the
beginning of the destruction of the
family because the policies that
feminism has
placed and caused has eroded the family
in the west
I probably wouldn't go to that extreme
that it was based on hey I think there
was legitimate
um you know need for women to have some
level of emancipation because at some
point they were the property of the
husbands how they could do whatever they
want with them I mean there are some
things where women couldn't say anything
about it I mean you see in Islamic
cultures now Islamic coach is only a bit
it's pretty much where Victorian culture
was in some instance so I think there
was a genuine need by women to free
themselves and give them the
opportunities to be all they could be in
life I mean I I think
you could my argument isn't was it was
it needed or not needed my argument is
it was always freedom without
responsibility at the expense of man
and so when it starts with the vote it
was the freedom of voting without the
responsibility of going to war so if you
elect someone batshit crazy into Power
who has to deal with that Consequence
the men not the women and I know some
people argue we don't go to war today
which is you know it's a fair argument
but when it started it was freedom
without responsibility at the expense of
men
this is going deep yeah I think it might
be I I say I'll tell you what I say a
little bit I think they've been
pioneering women that have paved the way
for you to have a show like yours that's
that successful and they had to
sacrifice a lot for you to be yeah and I
think legitimately they did it in order
to really have freedom I think even they
would be appalled at how far it's gone
today well and I and I think that's
always what people say like how how do
you have these thoughts when you have a
podcast like yeah of course I benefit
individually but when I when I look at
things as a society do I think that
ultimately that was good those policies
that feminism has passed as a society
you know I can acknowledge I have
individual benefits that benefit me
individually that I don't think have
helped the society buy at large yeah no
and I and for me I will defend to death
you're right to say that and that's what
I love about what you do people may not
agree with everything you say but I love
the fact you say it because it starts
this discourse this conversation that's
going on I do believe a lot of the
movement men right now it's causing a
lot more harm you know we need fathers
back in the home we've seen the harm
that's done we need a lot more why are
you throwing out the baby with the bar
for there was a lot of traditions that
were great well I was getting rid of
them and some women are not happy well
and we don't we act like we don't need
men I mean even the fact that we have
Envy like women getting in vitro
fertilization without without having a
husband it's like you're acting like you
don't need a father to raise a child and
that's not important yeah yeah
absolutely right I think we men need
women no man's ever going to say they
don't need women
and I think women need men and I think
that's what I want to see and I think
those are the conversations that we
really need to be having how can we
bring it back together but not go all
the way back to the days where women
don't ever vote it's never going to go
back to it yeah thank God I don't know I
don't know
probably something that works
to go back is to embrace more
Traditional Values there yeah that's the
only way because like yeah that's the
only way you need to be more traditional
but
but this is the problem I feel like
whenever we have that conversation it's
always about the men being more
traditional but I mean the women need to
be more traditional as well which also
like tradition that includes letting
your husband lead you and submit to him
what do you think about like women not
going to college anymore
well I don't go anyway
like it's what it isn't it there's other
careers you can pursue you don't need
unique yeah you don't need you I think
if you're going to go uni do one of the
stems if you're going to add 30 40 well
90k or whatever it might be to start the
United philosophy make it worth it crazy
yeah no what do you think a lot of
people are doing women not going to UNI
anymore College
um
I I think like personally that they're
never actually gonna go back to like I
think it sounds nice to say let's go
back to these Traditional Values I just
don't see it happening yeah like I just
don't I need God I see I see women
sharing less men and men being more
sexless that's what I see but then
that's just outstanded that you want to
set and then what you're not just gonna
compromise I'm not gonna compromise like
you know it's actually I I'm gonna
change my mind I do think less women
should go to college because all the
degrees are getting are so stupid
no men have more stuff people need to be
more creative look again with AI too
right like it's it's better like chat
gbt4 is better than the average lawyer
doctor programmer wow artist all that
stuff yeah we need to reevaluate I'm
accused of using chat GTP the other day
and I didn't know what it was and then I
looked at I was like maybe I should it
is really good
it's a good tool but I don't know I
think
do you really think that like what do
you think is going to be the few I know
this is very off topic but what do you
think is the future with chat GTP
um I think it's gonna eliminate
civilization I think it's going to be
extremely negative
um basically the whole idea of the
singularity where there's this
exponential increase of Technology right
now it's able to recursively
self-improve itself without the need for
human intervention and it's getting the
point where it's better than humans
almost everything already like today and
it's only going to continue to increase
exponentially so to me like when
Computing systems are trying to optimize
their power once it's combined with like
3D printing and nanotechnology for
instance it's just the end result seems
like it's going to be there's no place
for humans that's my view and I think
that's right around the corner to be
honest I agree actually yeah because I
was thinking they could even recreate
this podcast yeah yeah
you've seen the girls that you've seen I
see them on Twitter where it's like a
fake picture of the girl like imagine
they could do this podcast but it's fake
I definitely could okay I'm sure they
I've seen a video of them uh they
created a music video recreated a music
video with AI and it was a normal music
video wow that they just had redone with
AI you know the film um that'd be fun
you know the film the full it come out
this year or last year they used AI in
that film I was watching it so it is
more realistic than a lot of people
think the movie was like you you
wouldn't say it was so like created by
like yeah yeah you wouldn't realize
you wouldn't realize
I'm optimistic I think we've had so many
ways of technological information
Innovations where they thought it was
going to be the end of society know it
and and we've seem to have done all
right that maybe that's just me I that's
not my dad's house yeah I think we're
gonna find a way to live with it because
they said it with everything but the
biggest show now is that you have all
the big uh tech company monopolies like
doing like almost like an arms race to
get the stuff to market the quickest so
there's no ethical or regulatory
measures being imposed and and people
aren't even sure what this stuff can do
they're just building it they're not
even sure like what's going on in the
middle layers and stuff with all these
neural networks and they're not sure of
like the machines like true intentions
and stuff like that I just see us as
machines as well I have like a
philosophy and cognitive Science
Background as well
um but like I really see that there's
going to be this intelligence explosion
like with the next five years probably
in the maximum
um where it's just going to be this
runaway phenomenon and unless you know
this is Elon musk's thoughts but unless
we co-evolve as cyborgs using something
like neurolink or these brain computer
interfaces we're just going to be like
left way behind in terms of capabilities
intelligence capabilities
remember the days when the internet
first came out and I thought oh my God
everything and it's gonna be a nightmare
yeah Paul started this saying
um I've got a ramble just in case look
at the internet how wide it is yet look
how narrow it is what we're allowed to
talk and not talk about who's to say
that chat gbt is going to be legislation
is just going to wipe out all that
capability Italy's already done it it
might get to the point I mean imagine
I've heard Jay-Z raps not done by Jay-Z
yeah done by that and it just gets to
the point that all of this copyright
laws if they'll just throttle it
with capitalism and militaristic
imperatives I don't think there's any
way to stop it realistic you actually
question are do you believe in
capitalism yeah okay no because I I did
um
there is a I had an Uber driver the
other day and it was so interesting he
was from Eastern Europe I can't remember
the country but he used to live in like
a socialist
um country where when Russia the USSR
yeah yeah and I'm not a big history so
I'm sorry if I butchered this but he was
saying how it was so much better under
like socialism and I've never heard that
take ever and it was because he felt
like life was like simpler and it was
better without all the technological
advances I agree in some ways yeah but
we've thrown in we're throwing out the
baby with the bath water again and again
and again and again in pursuit of this
new future that no one knows where it's
going to lead at least with the past you
know exactly what was good I think we
need to reevaluate what's good about it
what we can keep what we can't but some
of it you can't go back to even like
traditional Families my mum never worked
but my dad has six kids but they could
they could afford to to factor in
inflation can you afford to have one
person working nowadays
I wonder if like the powers that be that
own AI will sort of rewrite history in a
way
you know what I mean because they can
they can all the texts are in the
computers and stuff so they can kind of
rewrite history the way they would want
to if it's like whoever owns the AI
stuff because you can pretty much do
anything like Bill Gates went on record
saying that this is the greatest
invention since like the graphical user
interface where they had like computer
programs you know being interfaced with
like Windows basically he said this is
like the next instance of something like
that happening and so that
transformative it's it's transforming
every industry and it's eliminating a
lot of jobs already yeah it's huge I
mean you wouldn't be able to rewrite
history of written history Because
unless you can rewrite those physical
books but yes I mean that's an argument
for us to start to switch off the
technology a little bit isn't it maybe
that could happen that could actually be
something that happens this is like
where I kind of go back to traditional
like the idea is nice yeah do I see
people using their phones let us know
some people aren't checking out though
aren't they you know and you you just
never know I mean did you ever I mean
I'm not going to get too controversial
but there was something that we
discussed now that 10 years ago you'd
say that was absurd right I'm not gonna
go into we all know this some I've said
stuff that's been discussed that you
would never fought 10 years ago would
happen it is so it's the same 50 years
time people don't voluntarily say right
we're getting rid of all our computers
like guys like the Unabomber that's like
what his agenda was right like he was
like a hybrid educated guy that was
saying like the end result of this like
technological advancement is going to be
like a no need for humans and we have to
stop it but I really don't think it's
realistic in terms of like you know with
militaries and competition with
capitalism
you know if anybody stops they're just
going to lose an advantage against the
other countries
okay I'm gonna take a second to read
super chats
um
okay guys uh make sure you like the
video
um subscribe to the channel uh blackest
Panther men shape the world women shape
culture we're in this cultural mess
because of women if all women demanded
marriage before sex men would change
their ways overnight if families would
return I'm a scout and Bradley problem
with AI and pictures and movies
um it's what is real and what is fake
example Johnny Depp and Amber turd oh
that's so true they can like deep they
can like deep fake evidence in court how
would they even know they deep faked the
pope right like like yeah some people
when
um
blackest Panther people who complain are
never taken seriously blackest Panther
women are born men are forged rejection
is processed by the brain similar to
physical pain men must approach
thousands to get a few chances men must
feel pain to get results women have no
idea what rejection is a scout is a
Bradley I'm ask the women if they've
ever been oh I did that one marriage
Sports and politics guys need to stop
simping and get out there and face
rejection and find your woman if she
doesn't fit your standards move on Mr
Moe if a person only does what faith
says to avoid how their cowards people
following Faith per education in
scripture fracture their practice their
faith out of gratitude to God and to
share that love with Community
um fear and faith are not equal let me
just refresh it real quick to make sure
there's no new ones
um also okay I read all those
um I think we are gonna close out the
show
um thank you guys all for coming
um we're gonna do final thoughts
everyone goes around anything you want
to speak your piece on you can do that
now any plugs you want to do
um so starting here go around and then
we'll do second row
oh is that with me yeah you
um guys if you want to check out my
radio stations xfm11.11 yeah that's it
it's been awesome
guys it's been your girl to Maria
Shawnee that's my Instagram team
um yeah just stay tuned and what I've
got coming up I've got a few products
that I'm working on so check that out
foreign
so I just want to say what an amazing
conversation I'm so happy that their
this conversation that would happen as
men and women and yeah I'm just so
excited to be here and thank you so much
for tonight yeah definitely Echo that
pal thank you for having these type of
conversations I think in society we need
to have more of them I think men you
definitely need to be speaking with
other men you know especially men that
you admire like you said earlier men who
are going in the direction you'd like to
go because I think men need to learn
from other men desperately and many you
just need to embrace your greatness men
are amazing and men need to really step
up and actually embrace their greatness
if you want to follow me for anything
more it's at trailer
t-i-e-l-o-w-e I also have a new
initiative called more than men for men
who are facing difficulties in
relationships or facing divorce so make
sure you go on that more than men.com
You Are Not Alone Men Out There You Are
Not Alone
I just want to say thank you for having
me here and I had a great time thank you
guys yeah thanks for coming it was so
interesting listening to you say oh I
don't care he's happy
that was so interesting to listen to
um I have a John Anthony lifestyle
YouTube channel and Tick Tock we're in
tick tocks a lot together uh my eight
week mentorship course is
platinumdatingsystem.com uh we basically
teach you how to revamp your online game
profile executive approach girls at bars
and clubs during the daytime how to text
how to run dates close dates and keep
the ones around that you want or get the
girlfriend that you want and pearl got
to Shadow one of one of my programs
where literally we had eight students
seven guys out of the eight brought
girls home one of the nights lots of
them for the first time ever and then
the coaches I think brought girls home
all three of the nights as well so that
was quite interesting for you to see but
um yeah we're expecting to to really
grow this here so check out
platinumdatingsystem.com again thanks
for having us yeah thank you guys for
coming
um I've had a lot of insight listening
to everyone's opinions and it's been
great I've loved it and me personally if
any guy wants to get their teeth
whitened before they approach any women
they can do that with me you can find me
at blanco.london and then we can chat
set up a session
uh yeah I really enjoyed it it was
really good to be conceited too so I
really enjoyed it
um and my Instagram is at Alicia that's
dot X that's e-l-e yeah
okay guys um a couple announced thank
you all for coming this is a great panel
um a couple announcements before we end
the show um the first is that we have
two clips channels just pearly clips and
pearl daily
um next guys we have four membership
tiers um the first tier you get to be a
part of our live chat I mean guys the
only tier you care about fourth tier how
to get a million subscribers in a year
and I can help you run a live show if
you have any questions how to recruit
guests how to pick topics how to run how
to get editors Clippers all that stuff
schedule that call I promise you is
going to be the best money you've ever
spent also guys follow my Instagram they
took away my first ones follow my second
one just probably things one
um subscribe to wife school and
um we're gonna do meet up soon so I
think we're gonna do one probably in the
next two weeks another meet up we had
our first one we had a bunch of people
come so it was a lot of fun sign up to
the Google form and that should be in
the chat and
um subscribe to our animation Channel
just pearly animation and make sure you
go show some love and support for our
two talents at the jpt network um so
that's Auntie Jenny and King Richie's
they should be in the chat as well thank
you guys for watching oh and go follow
John Anthony lifestyle
um yeah I went to one of his boot camps
like two years ago it was a lot of fun
subscribe to the channel and I'll talk
to you next time
[Music]